two
what's up everybody
whoa it's wednesday
august 17th a beautiful hot hot hot
it's hot out there
summer day my mic is flip-flopping
guys today's episode's sponsored by
honey
um
zach what's going on here is ethan klein
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
ladies and gentlemen we are all domestic
terrorists
hello
[Music]
[Applause]
anyone here from arizona
do not wait thank god sweet all right i
lifted the time embargo
you guys went crazy you gotta sit
through this my friends
[Music]
[Music]
i'm going to send it
yo can you put on astro world
like no no shotties or anything hold it
young fika thank you for the three
[Applause]
gifts um
[Applause]
hallelujah
[Applause]
hallelujah friend neil bent over this
happened
[Music]
what do we do about it how you go from
hallelujah
prolapse what do we do about it
[Applause]
oh my goodness
[Applause]
we lift the embargo and zach turns it it
takes how long was that
two minutes on the dock oh wow it felt
like a lifetime
that was a whole spiritual experience
man wow
what and god's earth was that this is
truly off the rails visuals brought to
you by ian yeah
i could see you guys collaborated on
that too like
yes
an extent we have not yet seen yes
always raising the bar here on the hd
podcast well that's that is true we are
revolutionary in the podcasting space
so thank you guys wow
wow did you catch your breath after that
thank you to prolapse penguin 20 gifted
subs today i don't know if you guys
heard it sponsored by honey also shout
out tomorrow
morning 10 a.m pst
peanuts is dropping
[Applause]
also everyone else has some swag
olivia's got some swag
cam's got some swag
cam's been talking about
it's over 90 degrees out right now and
it feels so cool in this i'm seriously i
[ __ ] love it this is so worth it
awesome i'm glad oh
oh
nice love is holding up well i do like
that shirt it's not peanuts but i do
like it
oh we said that we got that out to you
eh
yeah
thank you nice
what do people in sweden think about
that shirt i wonder if you walked around
in that love i've been walking around in
it and i haven't gotten any reactions
but i don't think people care i think
that's cool that's cool yeah
yes so teddyfridge.com
tomorrow morning charlie brown and the
peanuts gang thank you thank you peace
and love
we have quite an action-packed episode
today we have a big game planned
later on in the show we will be playing
guests
whose parents
wow so we got pictures
of everybody's parents
and i will have the singular duty of
matching them up to which crew members
holy smokes this is gonna be fun
and then do we have the sibling wild
cards as well
no no siblings we kept it there
we realized there's a lot of parents to
go through that's a lot of folks right
there
yeah
yeah so
[Music]
i'm actually super curious to see who
whose pair who's out there you know what
i mean
so that's going to be fun
we also have a massive beef coming up is
being squashed today
uh
way uh
the big old muscle bro from he's not i
guess he's he's cruises with now but
he's not part of now what's his name
bradley
bradley martin yeah we're gonna squash
the beef with bradley today may i call
you brad mr brad
be red
the brad
b brad b martin
yeah be red mark
and also we have
well
david dobrik also i love this man he's
still trying to kill people on his
crew he's awesome
but at the top of the show here we have
i want to give a shout out to jeremy
from the quartering longtime friend of
the show
it is the two-year anniversary
from jeremy peeing in his basement now
this is like
yes this is huge i mean we we we
celebrate anniversaries 911 pearl harbor
independence day i don't know today
celebrating 9 11's anniversary we
deserve a bit we introduced right yeah
we observe it
but so august 17th is i just been my
basement day and here let's just enjoy
this
you never know
you never know
sure don't maybe i'm gonna pee in my
trash can down here i don't know
my wife went out for pizza without me
and i'm angry about it yeah
so i'm gonna win this round and i'm
gonna pee
if i don't win this round i'm gonna pee
in my own basement right right right i
love how he says i love how he says my
own basement like it's an act of
self-destruction
i'm gonna do this to myself
i'm so angry at my wife get up
no
this is a leading voice on the right
actually
of youtube if you can believe that
and uh you can hear distant peeing if
you listen closely of course
oh i didn't realize he has a get woke go
broke
plaque that back here yeah it's from
target i got that for my niece actually
that's cool that's interesting yeah you
could have it say whatever you want
oh you let it say yeah my nieces doesn't
say yeah yeah yeah so so i don't know
that we need the whole uh break here i
have literally so here we go
i've literally never lost that round
i haven't ever lost that round
i've never lost that round
but i'm ready i'm ready now
this man
oh my god just peed in my basement
this man
wow
he's got his life together you can
certainly tell
you know whenever my wife goes out with
her friends without me i [ __ ] on the
floor so he's better than i am yeah he's
more evolved than he than me so whom i
did to uh make fun of him
but there he is
jerry is jeremy from the quartering
ladies and gentlemen
leading voice on the right
uh and there's [ __ ] all over the floor
he's a flat sack
and we love him we have to observe this
this wonderful day another thing that
came up from yesterday
which i'm not super happy about
also i don't know if this is a photoshop
or what
is that a photoshop i saw this seems a
tad receded i said that okay i'm the one
who said that is ethan still worthy of
the title hairline king uh oh but that's
a photoshop right yeah no i don't know
wait what was not who said yeah i did
cam it's very subtle but it's a
photoshop can we get a hairline thank
you because i was like bro come on and
well there's an easy way to let's get a
hairline check
oh look at my hair see it side by side
i'm pulling it back too that's the other
side
okay calm down
okay
[Music]
looks like when you guys posted when you
guys posted that in chat i was actually
editing the highlight and i don't think
it was a photoshop
love you oh yeah god forbid nobody could
photoshop something fast love nobody
ever heard of that
it had the appearance of a thick mat of
hair running so much defense the last
episode where is this coming from well
i'm still i'm still off of the
opinion that that isn't that bad i mean
even in that photo it's not bad it's not
bad for you
i have a title to uphold
no i think it's like actually still
green yeah yeah that's not
to be fair your hair could have been
sitting weird that day well i'm pulling
it right back so you tell me is that
photoshopped i'm pulling it back as far
as i can
yes yeah it's photoshopped thank you
i was freaking out at home i was like oh
hell nah
so you guys all knew it was photoshopped
and you're [ __ ] with me no i didn't
know it was photoshopped
i couldn't tell i couldn't tell i'm
still not totally convinced
what what what do i need to do today i'm
trying to i'm trying to find the
original so we can just look at the
frame from the look at my head right now
right but that's not what's in question
is is that a photoshop or not
the photoshop it could have looked like
that the other day yeah i think maybe
cameron the one man qualified to make
that distinction yeah it says it's a
photo shoot i don't want to put my
credentials
no i don't know i compared the frames
exactly yesterday when it was sent in
the shot it's pretty [ __ ] similar
yeah i mean this is the exact same you
gotta find that frame then
got to match that frame up exactly then
i mean i
you know like when a toddler wakes up
from a nap and their hair is like
plastered to their head yeah i figured
maybe something like that had happened
and it like parted your hair
specifically in that area if it's real
because that's what i thought normally
but i also can't tell if it's
photoshopped
we need a poll
[Music]
there it is olivia's right your hair
could have been sitting weird though
that doesn't make sense how do you show
scalp
because it it could be like here i'll
try to make it as fat as i can see
that's what i'm saying it still doesn't
look like that though yo is my hairline
but now turn to the side
check the shot
i sent the screenshot okay okay all
right
oh you got the exact screenshot okay
love god i think so
i took that yesterday when i was
comparing
i love that you're already on this
all right let's let's compare up now
okay interesting interesting i don't
think that's shocked
yeah yeah it came to that looks genuine
that looks genuine
well
but listen like today it doesn't look
like that so it's clearly just like a
flu yeah it's a bad hair day yeah it's
just about this is from the show
yes did you not photoshop this to [ __ ]
with me
no i'll keep the fruits
i need someone else to pull this up well
i found the part where you're talking
about it on the show right here
look at that right that legend looks
good that looks bad why is it
so high you were quick with that no
maybe because maybe this
is like right right around there that
frame
oh my god it's similar you know
sometimes maybe a different conditioner
or something could thin the hair
temporarily
did you
where did you wake up from a nap or
something tell me show me
okay before anyone makes any accusations
here's my hairline and pulled it back
all the way not many men would even dare
to do this
okay
[ __ ] dude
i sent you the file name file details i
gotta start taking rogaine and [ __ ] oh
wow okay we have the metadata here yeah
yeah dude if you take rogaine you're
look like cousin it like a week
yeah all right well yeah that's a that's
a genuine png right there uh how do you
tell if it's in photoshop metadata i
don't know yeah what is this no i mean
that is the name that comes out when you
screenshot it from premiere oh i see
what you mean yes god forbid you could
change the name of the file
yeah okay dude
could have brought a frame into premiere
and screenshot it from there too i'm
afraid it may not be i'm afraid it may
not be photoshopped
which is you know a heart a bitter pill
to swallow my friends
wow bottom line you're still the
hairline king i mean there's no denying
that are you sure yes we're [ __ ] sure
i don't know i've seen some good
hairlines lately like um we looked at
jason nash turns out he has an
incredible hairline somebody pointed out
yeah i mean i'm look at this [ __ ] bro
who the [ __ ] has beautiful hair like
that at his old age but it's combed
forward we need to get a total hairline
because it's also going back in the same
place that yours was
right well that's the classic receding
spot right
nobody's nobody's
perfect perfect right the hairline king
besides hold on let's take a look at
jason
airline
he actually does have a really nice
hairline but again it's combed forward
like
jason is
he's got that tick tock [ __ ] boy cut
he there i don't think he's he doesn't
have a better hairline than me
he might know
okay all right
oh my god look at this man
look at this man here
wow it does would you believe it it's a
friday once again
yeah
maybe that grows the hair maybe you
gotta start doing that ethan
daily weather report yeah on like npr or
some [ __ ]
well there it is okay let's not talk
about it anymore for now
no swirls in the chat god damn it
okay yeah so moving on uh there's that
i'm taking a lot of heat and then
there's also
a lot that took place with the cats i
may i've said i don't even remember what
i said well people were not down with it
i just said i'm not a fan of cats
yeah that's a problem
i'm not the only one you know why i
think that blame hassan not me look at
this [ __ ] i didn't see anything this bad
time and time again i'll be petting a
[ __ ] cat
and then cat will decide i no longer
want to be pet
literally going from purring to [ __ ]
trying to rip my fingers off bro that's
what i'm saying dude cat owners are so
psychotic dude
cat owners are so psychotic they're like
oh you didn't respect the cat enough
how am i supposed to know what the [ __ ]
you're literally you're doing it you're
victim blaming you're victim blaming i
didn't say it i didn't say it
those were hassan's words not mine
yeah but you know i've seen a lot of cat
memes on the subreddit
um i got i mean listen it got me feeling
bad i clearly
offended a lot of people oh god
[Laughter]
fish for asia to partner with a local
shelter and bring cats in for me to play
with
oh my god
let's get like 30 kittens in here yeah
you guys are just watching me die this
one really didn't help
what the [ __ ] kimi has two eyes a lot of
teeth and [ __ ]
personality he's the sweetest and has
never clawed me once
what's up what's up keem cat
king cussy what is the what's with this
sexy cat is that from the cats
movie i have conflicted emotions about
this i don't think this was a costume
featured in the film i think there's
just a whole genre yeah this is nothing
but that's from people like cats
but they also want to [ __ ] cats explain
that well you could say the same thing
about a dog yeah there's in fact i think
that's that's a bigger trend is it i
thought the cat thing the cat girl dude
there's so much like
dog horn like dog person porn out there
well we should really ask shane dawson
about this
[Laughter]
yep well
and at any rate if you want to [ __ ] him
if you want to pet them listen it's none
of my business
why are you so cute when you talk [ __ ]
but
there's that one
god uh you come to me and disrespect my
family
i know oh my god look at that cat
the god of cat yeah this is the one that
turned me you know i saw this one
immediately started apologizing willow
willow has one eye no teeth and
constantly wants human cuddles she's the
swedish has never called me once this
cat slander must stop yeah i i do
apologize to willow
okay
there's a lot of them i'm very sorry
this one ethan about to catch these paws
that one scared me
and this man uh has a pup and a kitty
yeah
what the [ __ ]
yeah so i got a lot of heat
and i'm
just it's a big-ass cat
holy [ __ ] right huge okay i'm not crazy
i had to hold him back when you heard
ethan slender could this cat like
protect your home
that's [ __ ] garfield dude someone's
gonna call joe exotic i mean
they've got cats cats can scrap so i'm
just wondering yeah
if we can train them to protect us dude
that cat had an evil eye on i'm afraid
of that cat
this big one yeah yo dude
[ __ ] you up
yo don't mention me to this cat whoever
you are
anyway yeah i apologize our whole
subreddit has just been unindated with
cat
posts
and um
i guess i should pull up the the podium
i mean
even cam is joining the
pile on look
i miss him this is from last night this
is my precious little baby angel
look at that look at that
i didn't say they're not cute i just
said they're not for me
[Music]
okay
one sec
is this thing all set up
oh come on you guys that's not right
[Music]
i am getting gang-banged by a bunch of
cat lovers
or cats themselves
i apologize to the cats of course you
are worthy of love you are great pets
even if
[Music]
you do cause brain infections
toxoplasmosis look it up
that's just a fact do you know what dogs
cause
mauled throats
mauled throat yeah yo take my throat
before my brain what are you talking
about dan what do you mean what am i
talking about dog attacks it's a common
thing
i've never seen one i never heard of it
you've never heard of it how many i'll
google this baby how many cat owners
have toxoplasmosis
it's like 90 percent dude this is
literally seems like it's not a big deal
then right because there's lots
this is like watching a cat in a dog
fight right now between you two
they don't know
but that's just a fact that's not i'm
not expressing an opinion about cats i'm
gonna say i don't like them that's just
a fact guys
okay and if we don't have facts what do
we have this is the worst facts don't
care about your feelings dan this is the
worst apology i'm not anyone i didn't
start my apology yet i'm just spitting
facts you know
ab what'd you find
seeing that 15 to 14 i'm sorry 15 to 40
percent have it but i'm trying to find
out
how the big number it's totally unproven
that it has some negative impact on
people they just don't know enough dan
exactly but you know what i do know
not a rottweiler
rip your [ __ ] face off okay no no no
i grew up with a rottweiler sweetest dog
i'm not saying they're the campaign wait
of course guys guys guys this is a
moment of healing
this is not
what i meant for this to happen
so even though they may cause brain
infections
that we don't have enough research to
draw a conclusion about one way or the
other
but we do know it causes mouses and
their brains to go
kill themselves so that cats can eat
them
good thing i'm not a mouse but but at
any rate what we do when we do want to
do clinical trials on humans what do we
use dan
mouses thank you
so anyway
rats technically
okay
so anyway
they are very cute they're wonderful
pets i apologize to all the cat owners
out there that i may have
offended
i don't remember exactly what i said
but uh
those of you guys who found the vlog to
be offensive i'm sorry you did for those
of you who didn't find it to be
offensive i'm sorry they did what he
said
yeah i don't know what to say guys i
mean i listen i i'll stop it
i didn't make that cat cry
[Music]
theodore loves cats he wants a cat but
i'm afraid that
because he's so young and the door gets
open the cat can run out and coyotes we
have a ton of coyotes in our
neighborhood and it could the cat could
die so i'm open to owning a cat
i'd like to own a cat
but we're just not at the time in place
it's a little
what little theodore opens and closes
the door all the time the cat's gonna
run outside
you have two small dogs and honestly a
cat is more equipped to get away from a
coyote than a dog they'll just climb a
tree but won't a cat leave our yard and
go wander around
you guys live in a safe neighborhood
safe hall there's coyotes everywhere all
the time
they'll be fine
dan is see dan wants kids to die i don't
who hates cats now
anyway peace and love peace and love
[Laughter]
wonderful apology well done
all right
see
i see i am remorseful i can make good
apologies
you don't think that's a problem it
scares me that if i get a cat and it
dies i mean that would be horrific no of
course that would be horrible that that
this is my favorite cat by the way
oh reuben
i know when i saw this i was like oh
this cat is a pooper trooper i can't
i can't think a bad thought about that
kitty
so there's that we're getting stuff out
of the way
animals die
hopefully not that's what i'm trying to
do i think dan should apologize for what
for
putting a hard line over all trials yeah
i didn't i didn't like that oh you i
love doc listen i'm not the one that's
hating on a precious little animal i
love dogs you just said dogs are
dangerous they're objectively more
dangerous to humans than a cat a cat
will scratch you oh no well a dog can
literally kill you are you talking about
i'm not saying well being an inch
scratch like because my dogs have never
hurt me but cats hurt me like regularly
with a scratch well your dogs are like
little moon toys i've been around all
kinds of dogs dan okay what about what
about wallace
his parents dog his parents dog has
literally
bitten me on the ankle until i was
bleeding wallace that happened so scary
yeah he bit me too actually can you just
say can you just say sorry to
rottweilers
yeah i love rottweilers i apologize
don't say it like that say it like you
mean it i do i love alfred say i'm sorry
to rottweiler i'm sorry rottweilers
they're great they're great pets i have
no problem with rottweilers
a rottweiler can kill you it has that
ability whereas a little cat is what's
what's the worst that's gonna happen but
to be fair you train the animal to kill
so i think you could
you could train the cat to kill we're
not passing judgment on any breeds here
i'm just stating a fact that a dog has
the ability to hurt you
so does everyone in the hospital's
office what is potential for her pain it
means nothing we have enemies everywhere
maybe i can kill you right now i know
choke you out i know but does she no
well i think a b would be the one that's
choking but
i mean
what amy amy's the most trained in
combat
yes extra shut up
trying to call me yeah yeah all right
enough we we love all animals
thank you thank you
uh also i want to give a quick shout out
this
this guy sugar hill rugs
i love this stuff man
these like artisan rugs they're so clean
he sent us some rugs dude these are so
sick
like look at this poco roast one and or
the
mirakashi one or whatever
takashi
so clean where's the um teddy fresh one
you sent us holding it up right now
or he was now he's holding up the
podcast one dude look how clean that is
how did he do it
so sick yeah so i want to give a shout
out to sugar hill
rugs
i want more rugs dude talk to me
i want to get a big one from you
of uh
of howie's prolapsed anus can we
commemorate that in a row
yes
i want that they're just massive in our
office all the time yes
i love that's horrific
and just like uh picture perfect
you want me to ask him
i'm curious what he says i'm a little
curious i mean how funny would that be
for howie's we have to have that that'd
be so [ __ ] hard i'll spend whatever
it takes man okay i'll see if he can do
something
[Music]
you know speaking of how it's prolapse
on my mission and never let this die
it's actually taken a life on its own
how we
finally got uh poked and prodded into
talking about it
check this out so
uh joel mchale was on howie's podcast
and somebody on the crew
is tick flash's
the prolapse on screen
and it's so good because how he gets
genuinely upset and joel just wants to
know what the [ __ ] was that and so
the memory of this prolapse lives on
and this is this is what i love watch
talk
that's it people make a lot of money
doing that oh i'm
making a fortune a fortune that's cool
why does he say it like that how much is
how we making on tick tock
that took me by surprise yeah i wasn't
sure if he was being ironic maybe he
might be in our yeah yeah that might be
how he's super rich so it's like a
fortune what the hell
okay maybe he's joking
i have a tick tock account but i've
never actually made one well maybe uh
during this or after this episode we'll
dance okay
yeah we'll find out what dance is that
what you do that's the house my dad's
really good at tick tocks i dance i'm
not don't say that
why not why can't she say
that that's perfectly fine hey hey hey
no so somebody threw it up okay and then
howie panics
which i love love love no
um no
no no he specifically said is that a
rabbit dish
specifically you can see it in the
reflection on the right oh is that right
yeah i just noticed okay let me see
you'll see a big patch of red appear and
then he's like scrolling around
oh yeah yeah you can see how his dome
and the red the
uh the trademark red
who did that we'll background that okay
anyway have your anus prolapse at some
point did something happen was it during
a tick-tock dance we'll talk about it
later we'll put one up we'll put one up
but uh oh no put up the uh anus again no
put up the one wheel
put up one wheel prolapsed there it is
yeah put a put a video there see when
does this air part mean no we don't know
we don't when does this air when does
this air oh if you're listening to it or
you're watching it on youtube uh right
now yeah
okay
oh we're watching it now you were
showing that prolapse dana's live no
that was shown on the screen and now i
can't talk about it no no because the
person that put it up on the screen
is going to pass away who did that how
he posted it who did it love it alex are
they going to blame it on alexa
so so he was pointing to himself alex is
my homie you know we had a little bit of
a tiff but we're dogs now and i consider
this a public service basically this is
he's done he's doing this for me
yeah we're dogs for life
uh me and alex were dogs for life if you
ever need anything from me but dude let
me [ __ ] know
anytime anything
what do we do about it i'm available to
you my dude
legend alex w alex wallace
oh i think it was what is like he was
talking about how terrible you are at
tick tock i actually said he was really
good at talking to him and then someone
said you weren't or whatever whatever it
was and then i figured you know what you
should talk about it it's a clip thank
you you screwed up
and we you know he wants to thank you
bro
that's what i keep saying and do it on
our show not yours
nothing
it's the internet yeah it'll never go
away but i think you should sell it so
understanding that why would you put it
up i'm i told everyone here don't show
it just let them see it and then that's
you could either talk about it or you
don't like you say if you have something
you have an idea for we can always edit
this isn't live i made a mistake but
you're bringing up he said it was live
that it's live on youtube right now live
on youtube i think you should talk about
it we could decide later yes listen to
your son
listen to your son howie
you can't avoid this any longer
we're forcing this moment to its crisis
w alex wallace howie you must discuss
the prolapse
he keeps dodging by the way
so the door the door is still
open to you my friend but it is we got
me in trouble
okay you posted a tick tock that came
back to bite you is what you're saying
yeah or somebody said
i didn't like that and you responded to
that person i didn't respond i took it
down he has been he it was
that he does not want to respond or talk
about it
[Music]
i'm always what part of that
[Laughter]
sometimes you want things to you know
what when i started this business if i
made a mistake it would go away well
yeah because now if i make sure movies
back then and no one's that old
yeah pretty old
anyway i have some stuff that i i've
made some mistakes recently
so you've you said you made multiple
mistakes recently no i said i made a big
mistake recently you know what makes
this better is just
that he's so ashamed or embarrassed by
it that's what makes it so good if he
just owned it and laughs about it this
wouldn't even be a thing it's the
it's the dodging okay that makes this so
[ __ ] fantastic and the prolapse and
the prolapse
yeah and the prolapse
right
and uh on the internet you posted a tick
tock that was a that was problematic yes
okay
and
does anybody talk about it now
what is this conversation no no because
it became a thing here in this room with
the people you would with all these
white people you employ oh
as you know these things go away very
quickly especially if they're not about
me
more especially when they're not spoken
about
nope
i won't speak about this till i die
by the way
pretty interesting that he's like what's
the deal why doesn't this go away can i
take can i own that personally do you
think oh yeah definitely yeah okay good
you've been spreading the good word like
the others
yeah yeah for sure this is the gospel
or when you
shine put it in the light no this should
not be in the light anymore what the
hell did you do in this dance that was
was it the prolapsed anus dance
wait did you put that in a tick tock
that is so great it is that's what i'm
saying you couldn't own it however
be the prolapse become the prolapse
[Laughter]
is that true
that's amazing
that's amazing
[Music]
this is not that i feel like it's not
that controversial it's not it's i mean
it's not really
it's something is it
go on the internet you by yourself after
this you go searching touch his phone
no not here yeah here's the pg version
by the way that we've uh
made that so that we can share this on
our show
and um
well
there it is you guys can use this image
it's safe for work anytime anywhere
to commemorate this okay here's what i
want to say i usually am uh
relatively aware of things that are
happening not today uh but
this is the first time i've ever heard
of this okay
good not the last so guys i don't think
it's that big of a deal when you don't
talk about it this is the this is the
problem this is like saying yes you know
like right effect right now she had been
a prostitute until she met your grandpa
and be like well okay i don't know but
what
where are they going with that we can
look
and let's talk about it let's bring it
out oh you have a grandparent that was
oppressed yeah all of them
[Laughter]
so anyway this i thought was pretty
great this is the closest we've got
to him actually discussing
this was also posted i was posted twice
no
yeah what's interesting about this howie
is if you search howie
uh
mandel
let's see what happens i heard that the
top news article yeah check this out
of course we've clicked it howie mandel
prolapse video shocks the internet
newsweek
i mean it shocks the internet it's
[ __ ] awesome
let's see oh yeah see it's not even that
far up here if you put tick tock the
first one that come came up for me was
how howie's tick-tock
what was it you may not want to know
okay i said howie mandel tick tock
oh [ __ ] the first result is howie mandel
tick tock prolapse full video
and then discover how mandel prolapse
video popular videos
i'd like to discover that
what was howie mandel's deleted tick
tock video
howie mandel's tick tock shocked the
internet
howie mandel traumatizes tick tock with
now deleted video
howie mandel's deleted tick talk at 5am
it's interesting to see how they all try
to
put some sensational you know twitter
yeah it's like a jstation title but the
the truth is the reality itself is so
good it doesn't need any
it's probably the greatest thing to
happen to the internet in the past 10
years i think it's up there sure yeah
right up there with fortnite
fortnite somebody suggested a uh
a website um
dellprolapse.com
[Laughter]
i'll do it oh my god we could totally
deal with that [ __ ] bro
should we do it but but
your dog's with howie i think that would
cross the line into like genuinely yeah
yeah hurting his friends
i don't want to do anything okay i will
not do it no don't don't don't i mean we
probably could sell it to him black
millionaire
no no no no no we're not no no we can't
do that we have to save that power for
when we really need to inform the public
about something urgent and interesting
and of public concern
speaking of which if you guys want to
head on over to google
type in ryan kavanaugh it's been a while
since we've done this interesting
right kevin is the guy of course that's
suing us
drive angry
drive angry
and if you go down oh man we've dropped
off quite a bit here
um but here it is it's stall
it's still all here uh a comprehensive
analysis
yeah so
do we have anything new here on the
website love
no just the same old very informative
though
i wonder if we could um
we got to update this so the people you
know oh this well this one's this is a
good video that is a force of nature
yeah
yeah
how ryan cavanaugh failed to deliver a
million dollars to charity
right exactly all that more three
million dollars yeah so guys
google ryan kavanagh go check out this
website uh educate yourself
thank you
so i don't know this howie meme keeps on
giving you gotta see the tick tock i
just dropped from him from three hours
ago i dropped it in a discord there and
by the way i'll open it by the way
speaking of
ryan kavanagh and howie
i talked about this right that they know
well they know each other
a little bit
yeah how he uh sold his house yeah ryan
kavanagh oh interesting
thank you sarah thank you ethan ela and
the crew my father passed away last
month and grief is kicking my ass
the goofs and gaffes have entertained me
through
the sleepless nights ethan is the
funniest mfor in my opinion well thank
you
you all bring me joy
thank you sarah i'm sorry you're going
through that but
we will be here for you
we will be here
thank you for the kind message
what the [ __ ]
all right here's howie's new [ __ ]
do i need to mute this
yeah it sounded like
zach's got it it's more the visuals oh
howie's pretending
that it's him
okay that's pretty good
all right
yeah that's not bad it's reminiscent of
his greatest hit it is prolapse oh it is
prolapse here you're right it is
prolapsish actually if you pause it at
the right minute like here
it looks a lot like it
yeah so anyway
shout out to uh howie we love you
and especially big thanks to alex
wallace w alex
[Applause]
okay we're gonna do our break this so
i know you guys don't can't handle the
jimmy lee stuff but this war is actually
going it's escalated the war between
jimmy lee and arab world news
uh so i mean there's a lot to report
arab world news dropped a full out dis
video on jimmy
so this man
he's sweet
but don't don't
cross him he'll bite you arab world news
please clap versus audio audio audio
what a [ __ ] guy he's a meme lord
well
four minutes of pure
warfare
love that
so let's thank our our thank honey real
fast we have one sponsor and then we'll
get into all that uh thank you thank you
to honey
yes
today's episode is sponsored by honey
the easy way to save when shopping on
your iphone or computer
i love honey i have it on all my
browsers so does ela gila is
consistently saving
money she's always buying [ __ ] and
luckily with honey installed
g-fuel
yeah that one's from love so you oh you
pay for g-fuel
love does um that one's for me yeah oh
it's from cam i'm sorry yeah yo 30 off
that's insane about this one right here
yeah
i probably spent uh like saved hundreds
of dollars with honey on gfuel yeah
thank you
it's it's almost too good to be true but
it's not it literally just scours the
internet for the best coupon code
available at checkout and automatically
applies it at checkout you don't have to
do anything just install the honey app
which is basically just two clicks on
the app store
and it's you're good to go it just
passively works in the background
you don't have to think about it dude
yeah
um
honey also doesn't just work on desktops
now it works on your iphone too
you can activate it on safari on your
phone and save on the go if you don't
already have honey
you are straight up missing out on
savings and by getting it you'll be
doing yourself a solid as well as
supporting this show
i use honey i love honey i think
everybody here uses i don't know who's
not using honey use honey it's crazy
i would never recommend this if i didn't
use it well
i do
get honey for free at jointhoney.com h3
that's
joinhoney.com h3 thank you thank you
with peace and love peace and love donny
this is a serious message
yes so we actually have a lot of things
i'm wondering what's the best way to
organize this time-wise because i want
to make sure we get to the parents game
and also we have this huge triller
lawsuit thing i want to get to maybe
just do a monster episode today i don't
know
it's just so much to get to
the addison ray bikini
thing
you know
blasphemy oh and of course david dubrick
right
but let's finish i guess so guys just
trust me this is good jimmy lee
verse arab world news this is the battle
that nobody asked for but here it is we
have to
we have to observe this
blue is my comedian legion to jimmy give
me something funny about you british you
look british with the teeth
you're mexican yeah
don't take anything
table 37 leave
work with me we're going to try it right
now follow me turn around zach and do
your stick do your do your catchphrase
work with me let's try it again
yo he burned him with that little [ __ ]
he's right nobody's laughing nobody's
laughing and it gives a thumbs up in the
corner you see that dude jimmy you're
getting [ __ ] owned by arab world news
but i gotta not do full screen cause you
can see his reactions here in the corner
which is important yeah
he's a funny guy he's a funny guy
hello everyone welcome my channel again
you for all love and support from my h3
family love you forever love you forever
bro comedian star jaime moog demi and my
beautiful camel yes so
please collab to my camera
you know just grab your hair
what can i do with my comedian jimmy
i will make him laugh little
like he
draws smile on our faces much
so
i am the kings now listen to me i hope
you heard me okay
and then nothing is wrong
wiz
your mind
in egypt we have a beautiful camels
especially in the pyramids and the santa
catrine
i invite you
visit egypt and see our handsome
comments
i think you will like it i will give you
the one like this as a gift
[Music]
yo
he's got the stunt camera waiting for
your ass jimmy what the [ __ ] is up al
lemmy
[Music]
[Applause]
we need to call arab world news arab w
news now
um yeah yeah
egypt come and your man
camels
loves the ball personality disorder
that's it
oh
[Applause]
good makeup
but say goodbye to your hairline as i
did
[Music]
say goodbye to your hairline like i did
with trump um that's in reference to he
had a video posted the other day
making fun of trump and he used a bald
filter and put it oh okay okay so that
that's for fans of his show yeah exactly
it's a callback
[Music]
bengal bengal so
what is the meaning of the bengal
allah
[Laughter]
is it
speaking arabic lena
it sounded like yeah but it was weird i
don't know i want it should i go back
you want to try to catch that yeah let's
hear it again okay
[Laughter]
[Music]
oh and then this well this parrot is
talking to the h30 family so uh let me
know if you hear something
lena you're so cute
hey that one's just giving a kiss and
you're getting your shirts next week i
even got one for dan who hates me
i really do he included this i didn't
say that only people will not like you
if you continue in this way
you must respect the other people in
your damn deep research
oh my god that's from the ends
this man has done his research that's
the old h3 video and actually he's
skewering him and where he's on the same
page as us he's saying yo bro you got to
change
yeah
that's where i'm at teaching at the top
is easy but keeping at the top is so
hardest so you can choose
anyway at the end of the video please
give me your feedback and the way many
surprises for you thank you for watching
surprises all around baby's done
jimmy's career is over
yeah
he ended him jimmy ross
rossi
what's his name steve rossi just fired
jimmy
he's warning you with peace and love no
more camel jokes thank you thank you you
can't spell lee without l
l
l
he also posted this one
uh when he's preparing for war against
jimmy he said
he says dear great comedian jimmy you
are really dangerous you made arab world
news wake up for 24 hours without sleep
well well it seems like he did put a lot
of research and work into that that's
true
for this uh this is for a video i'm
preparing about you starting with
writing the video script then the
difficult step is the process of
searching and searching
and choosing the proper memes and
filming as well as editing and editing
the most difficult out of all this is
language
i'm doing it on my own to make the h3
family happy
thanks for all the brothers who help so
my h3 family wait and enjoy this crazy
hilarious video
it was worth the wait
it was worth the wait
arab w news ladies and gentlemen
shout out muhammad
dude is that his name ahmed oh
am i putting too much stink on the edge
a lot of people do yeah and a lot of
people can say non-native speakers can't
really say ahmad
or they over emphasize
it's like where are you getting from
i think it's well in hebrew that's kind
of what that sounds like
that kind of situation no i wasn't
calling you out i just met no i can i
get it
you know just be more sensitive next
time
it is a syllable that is not common in
english to yeah emphasize that h so much
so yeah if jimmy has any thoughts he can
text you but he can't call in okay zach
got it yeah we need to curate him
so
um oh my god you got you guys are not
gonna miss this update so we gotta hold
a sea man
we had the ninja foot pick that was
right up his alley
and we said man we gotta send this to
sea man
we but we couldn't believe what we were
seeing
and dan you worded it like i said and he
got right back to you didn't he
uh
yeah i did
i think i worded it a little different
than how you oh
i just i didn't want to scare him away
you didn't he responded immediately bro
it wasn't immediate but but he did get
back to me like the next day here's what
c-man said about those he said and this
is for ninja if you're watching
not bad
but he's wearing flips so i find that a
turn off
but would be hot to see them hit the
pedals
yes they are hot
yep
and then he sent a follow-up one yeah
like a few minutes later he read a
message he says can we see him barefoot
and in socks too so he's actually
he wants more he wants more and in fact
maybe i can ask ninja if he can
send us please
we've got that in now yeah we're buddies
we squashed the beef i'm just gonna say
i know this is weird but yeah
how do i how do i broach that with him
to try to get it from him that's a lot
of lore
to just dump on somebody i don't know
obviously i say yo this sounds weird but
can i get a picture of you
on you're doing your pedals without
flip-flops one with flip-flops and one
with socks
no barefoot i mean right
that's doable
i'm gonna see i'm gonna see i'm gonna
try to explain this to him and tell him
it's important
you're gonna dm him i'll do it right now
uh i think it would be easier after the
hundred gifted subs that we pledged
uh maybe we can ask it afterwards you
know
what was that sound by tank
did
what happened why well why did we
shorten it the pit it's just that's how
he gets herself is that as short as
possible
get he's actually saying thank you for
the gifted right there
five gifted
five gifted
dude
i'm going to try i'm going to do my best
it's just
wait is this real like does this just
come through from gideon well you can
click it and see if it's real yeah i did
it's right it is real
jd and said hey ethan when you're done
with this segment could i please join to
say some words
uh yeah you didn't have to donate though
i followed you on twitter so that
w dan you could dm me if you wanted
oh he did dm me he said
ethan that thumbnail question was made
by my clips editor i literally don't
upload or run my second channel he's
changing it now
peace and blessings
that was uh i even threw that out as a
theory that it probably wasn't him and
so well we
there was some because he had commented
on the video
oh we were like well
but i i believe him that his uh editor
made it yeah when i mean we have the
same setup here and love makes the the
highlight clips and stuff so well yeah
but
just you gotta chill so you gotta have
some standards and pulses there
yeah that's kind of weird i'm not gonna
lie
but anyway he's changing it though okay
uh witty and w when
i'm down to have them on though just to
squash the two beefs in one day that
would be that would be strong two beefs
one cup so um do you yes do you how do
we reach you willian or
just give me the link and i'll i'll send
it to him yeah i could do that
w dan
yeah gideon is this youtuber we talked
about him on monday
he uh
he said that i'm a liberal racist
and in the thumbnail it put texts a text
bubble of me saying this guy looks like
an orangutan or some [ __ ] like that
which obviously never said uh just uh
sent it in our whatsapp group if you
want to pass that on so i was like man
that that seems kind of [ __ ] up to put
that out there
um
so here but i got it
wait where'd you put it dan w we're in
our uh what's up group
oh so i'm gonna see anyway
i'm gonna send him the link
so it oh
wait ian if you want to join here's the
zoom leak you can you can connect okay
here sending it to you on twitter
twitter dm
okay
there you go very nice though i
appreciate that you know i appreciate
that
that he's changing the thumbnail
i know apology that's that's good that's
nice
yeah so i'm gonna work on getting those
foot picks from uh
from ninja though i think there's a way
should i tell him that it's for a foot
fetishes or or just going to be like
yeah i feel like it's
i don't want to be the party pooper here
but it's it's a little weird like
there's a lot of bro it's funny
i i'm not denying that it's funny but to
like go to ninja and be like hey
we sent a picture of your foot to this
guy
that masturbates to feet and he said
it's really hot can you send us more
pictures like that
seems maybe a little far wait is this
the new thumbnail
look at him act like an educated
african-american
now what the [ __ ] does that mean
i don't know
that's still kind of weird bro
isn't it
yeah you want to ask him yourself he's
in the chat or he's in the lobby right
now i gotta pee so bad
let me just run to the bathroom bring
him in
i'm just gonna run the bathroom so we
can have a i don't have to worry about
this
okay
bring him in dan
i'll bring him in when he gets back
uh
blah blah blah
w dan
i'm looking through some of these donors
there's jillians
uh
the sarah one we already read prolapse
penguins we already shouted out we
didn't shout out
monday's dark
ethan which appears to be our saudi
prince
so thank you for the 50 gifted
tit
listen to short people by randy newman
it's an insane song there's lots of good
sound bites i i am very aware of that
song
um
my wife on our honeymoon no jillian no
jd and no jd and guys i mean
we can talk to people all righty and his
name is bestie y'all better hold back
bite your tongue don't talk about him
like that stand up stand up for ginny
yeah i mean it's content right i mean
whether whatever you think about him
it's content it's content baby
entertainment it's entertainment dude uh
it's my birthday i'm 22 i'm related to
helen keller
i am so sorry to hear that
sorry about that
so sorry about a happy birthday i don't
know about you but sorry about your
homework you don't hold the sins of your
ancestors against you i don't know about
you but you're feeling 22 my friend
for reals
hey dan i got a new boyfriend well
congratulations goof man
shout out goof man
shout out
uh
blah blah blah
just please don't get another strike i'm
not gonna get my strike it's all good
it's all good baby
[Music]
um
mary just said donated 20 said i just
passed my
nclex i'm not sure what that is i'm
officially a registered nurse that's
what it is
[Applause]
is that what they're worried about what
is he
no he's not banned oh okay they lifted
the one strike that was yeah hey bring
him on let's talk all right here we go
stand back
this is our sam cedar moment yeah that's
what i was going to say love
what you think he's going to like blast
me with
all right we'll see hello yeah i have a
legitimate play me like that would you
uh he's there i see his audio doesn't
look like his videos coming through yet
though
gideon is joining us
i heard his voice a second ago yeah i
heard him say hello i mean who could he
bring out that would even that i would
even care keemstar but that would be
epic i literally would be so excited
you know what i mean like it's not that
big of a deal a rule
yeah
[Music]
um
gideon is trying to set up he is a
twitch streamer which is orwell are you
did was he banned on twitch yes
he's a streamer
that doesn't know how to turn on his mic
and video
i mean he probably is used to using
discord he's maybe just figuring it out
right now i guess we'll just give it a
minute i see this hello
[Music]
we hear you
gideon yo
mercy
i need your help
oh he's screaming for help how do you do
zoom yeah he is the culture let's just
give him a minute he's he's there
yeah take your time there bud we'll see
first
how do you do zoom
yeah we're trying to uh i don't know if
you you're hearing us but we can hear
you we just don't see you
oh this is can does you know that
they're just oh [ __ ] yeah we can hear
you
like y'all hear me yeah yeah we hear you
we hold we heard you screaming for a
person your grandpa right now yo sorry
chat
no problem
this zoom is born to me i am a discord
user yeah first thing first i want to
say when in the chat
shout out
see a lot of ledeons
w
i haven't seen that many lydians in the
chat before but you know hey
something new but i can't hear anything
right now oh oh you can't he can't hear
us well then well interesting i see
y'all but not much of a dialogue
we can try uh
we can try uh discord if you want really
connect there
you want to tell him that i can i can
maybe just hang up video
this is just
i mean we can wait by any chance you
don't have anything dude he's getting
close
can you hear us julian you hearing us
he asked about this court just now
yeah maybe just uh
can i send him the discord link
okay
maybe just hang up dan yeah man when
i can't hear you yeah okay listen let's
let's kybust this okay
oh
is he responding to me on the show
no it's too delayed i think why don't
you message him say we can try discord
did you hang up i'm hanging upright okay
good all right
his next video
i trolled
h3 live on stream
[Music]
i'll send you a discord uh link
at least he said when before he left oh
yeah he gave a big shout out we'll just
have to
add
as friends so let me give you my like
discord
name or whatever oh he said he figured
it out
oh
should we we're done you can just click
that link again then we're definitely
he's not banned
no no no i think
i don't think we're being i don't think
he knew he knew how to use zoom do you
think we're being controlled
absolutely no he kept saying he was the
discord are you just returning the zoom
let's see if it works well if it doesn't
work again then it doesn't work again
we'll do this not that good of a troll
it's just kind of funny
all right i'm letting him back in okay
he's back there we go
all right gideon can you hear us this
time
yeah i can hear y'all there you go okay
hey welcome back to the show thank you
for calling
no thanks for having me jillian nice to
uh meet you nice to talk
uh oh i just feel like it's been like
you know
there we go can you see my face now
there we go okay what's up
what's up ethan how you doing nice to
meet you
uh first thing first
when i love you bro
shout out
yeah so
uh my editor was kind of telling me
about the video i haven't got the chance
to
watch your response yet because i was
going to watch it later on my stream but
he had told me that you were really
upset about the thumbnail
and um
i really don't even look at my second
channel he just posted the clips and
stuff
so when he told me and i saw it i was
like oh [ __ ] i said change it so okay
that's nice i appreciate that the new
one's a little weird though too maybe
you can explain this it says
look at him act like an educated
african-american i don't know what that
means
um
i think i know what he was trying to go
for there
what
talking about your best friend keemstar
i think
a little play on words look at him act
like a educated african do you not like
that one if not i don't get it it seems
like it's another
that not that i know of
did you tell them after this to change
it for you yeah so so
i guess well since you're here
i guess we can talk about the uh
the video because you accused me of what
i felt was like a light jab about the uh
about the uh the most racist town in
america video you made
yeah
you called me a liberal racist and i
i am intrigued by that i just was hoping
you unpacked it a little more
in your video so maybe you can do that
for me here
nah yeah um i don't think i called you a
liberal racist because me personally i
don't think you're a racist you know
but you said that verbatim i said that
was liberal racism okay okay this is
liberal racism so because i said the
same thing about hassan so okay so
liberal racism what does that mean
so i feel like you know i feel like you
know what conservative racism is right
you know your
white picket fence
all-american family you know
hates immigrants doesn't like you know
the stereotypical racist right
and so that's the pretty much when you
think of a racist you think of someone
that's outwardly like i hate black
people you know people that are against
blm
that's what i think of you know with
racism but this yeah i got you i feel
like what uh kind of comes under the rug
and people really don't talk about is
liberal racism and what i think liberal
racism and a lot of other black people
in black in the black community we feel
like what
liberal racism is is like
white people thinking or not even white
people but it's mostly white people
thinking they know better than black
people thinking like they have to save
us more like a white savior complex like
you know i'm very pretty sure you heard
a white savior right yeah yeah i know
what that is
so that's what i mean by liberal racism
so i just felt really patronized when
you were like oh look at him parading
for the kkk
and yeah it was a light jab and stuff
and i got emotional so you know that's
not me for getting emotional you know i
should have articulated my words a
little bit better to get my point across
but
you know we all say things we regret
right
oh yeah i don't necessarily regret it
but i regret how i phrased it so what
how would you like to phrase it because
i am interested in unpacking that
i just felt patronized you know
yeah
so
like because i guess the criticism of
that video was just that
you went there and you're like this
these guys are all like we can talk with
these people and we can have a
conversation with them you're talking to
that kkk guy who was basically like
you can't come to my church
right yeah yeah he said that
and uh he thinks that like whites and
black people should be separated
he does so
i guess i just don't
well before yeah you kind of just gave
him a platform to talk uncontested
that's all yeah yeah um i want to hear
from you what is in that situation
for you to have not said that what would
you have liked me to like say or condemn
him on in that situation well first i'll
say i think the we all see that the
video had um
good intentions and you want to and like
we get what you're trying to do out
there and
you know i think and i've made this
mistake before
when i've had people like jordan
peterson on or even joey salads i once
debated him and the problem is when you
talk with people that incendiary with
that
like
undefensible and a lot of them lie and
mislead [ __ ]
uh you kind of have to be equipped to
respond to it appropriately right you
kind of have to be
prepared otherwise they're left to say
whatever they want kind of unchecked
and in a way you kind of just let the
guy give his platform out
and without being you know without
challenging him in a way that that i
think would have been meaningful
but that being said you know i
understand what you were trying to do
and it was so do you feel like i came in
there like unequipped and you know i
wasn't prepared
really and i just kind of gave him a
platform like if that's your opinion
that's your opinion but is that what you
think i came in there unequipped i think
that you
are
yeah a little bit yeah for sure okay
yeah well to say to that actually
i know
you know from the title it's kind of
like you probably were thinking oh yeah
he went there to
you know
say racism doesn't exist but actually
when i i don't know if you realize the
outfit i had on i was like sagging had a
white tank top i really had no idea what
type of video i was going to do there
yeah because i've never been there i
just seen the video and stuff but when i
got there got to talking to the
minorities of the place
figuring out and then learning that okay
it's not actually the town of harrison
it's this little town of zinc where you
know the kkk compound is then going over
to zinc finding out it's not even the
town of zinc it's literally just that
compound and how pretty much everybody
in that area doesn't like them and you
know i got everybody else's opinion
about it you know everybody was cutting
them out talking about how much they
disliked them and then you know i go on
his property to go talk to him and me
personally you know i feel
as though to grow as humans
like if i was just to go there
and he talked and i'm like you [ __ ]
racist you're wrong you know obviously
yeah would have got a lot of clicks
would have got a lot of views and
everything but at the end of the day
what would have got done i feel like i
don't think that's the only way to
confront people right i mean you don't
have to yell and scream and stuff
like that would be i don't know for me
it's like if i go to like neo-nazis and
be like yo we can have a conversation
you just you just want me to [ __ ] die
but i don't know i get what you were i
get you we were going for it right and
it's like you know let's say you know
you're jewish right yes
so let's say you did a video where you
went to like a neo-nazi camp
and you had a conversation with them
and for the most part it was a silver
conversation he said we you know
he has to say which is absolutely wrong
and i don't agree with
and then you know you say your piece and
then you leave it at that and let's say
i was to hop on and be like oh look at
ethan parading for the neo-nazis you
know he's all i didn't say you're
parading just i think you said
campaigning if i'm not mistaken i think
you said pl i think i said like giving
him a platform
i think he's like campaigning but you
know it's all good though it's all good
well what it doesn't matter but my
intention was that you i didn't say
campaigning
but i mean i don't feel like it doesn't
matter because because it to me
it offended me you know and i know you
like talked about keem and everything
keem said and like bro you know i'm not
stupid we all know the video where keem
set the hard r like what three four
times
and you know me personally i don't
consider him a racist like you know no
offense you said the hard r like two
three times i don't consider you a
racist you know like people say stuff
it's like i know a racist and i know you
know someone that just says something
and that guy was a racist but i knew
going there that he wasn't going to
change his mind and that's not what i
wanted to go there for i'm not going to
to try to change his mind because it's
just not going to happen and i feel like
that's the problem where the left and
the right get into an endless debate
where one side tries to say changes the
other side's mind then the other side
gets mad that they're trying to change
their mind so they want to rebel against
them and it's another ending thing i
just wanted to put out there what they
thought and then i feel like the rest of
the video spoke for itself is like even
though there's as much hatred why do you
want to put out whatever in the city or
why did you want to put out what they
thought
it's the same reason why you know you
talk about andrew tate you know
it needs to be talked about did you
criticize it though
i did i feel like i mean i feel like
it's pretty obvious that i stand against
everything he says yeah i think i can
boil it down to this point which is
basically
there's some things that are not even if
you engage it
it legitimizes it in a way that like it
doesn't even need to be engaged like
it's not even a conversation like if i
went to a nazir i was like tell me about
why you think all jews should die it's
like that's not going to be a productive
conversation simply by the fact that
there's no
real way to justify that and even by
engaging it like it's a like a a
reasonable argument you you in a way
legitimize it and turn that conversation
into what like a legitimate conversation
that's really not
it's not a legitimate conversation
that's why i wasn't adding on to it
that's why i wasn't agreeing with him i
just let him talk and i said well why
can't i join the church it was more to
flesh out everything that he thought
because when you really get down to it
he said everything he thought and then
he ended up saying that more white
people
uh hurt him and offended him more in his
life than black people so it's like okay
if white people did more bad stuff to
you in your life than black people but
you'll let white people into your church
then why is this hatred of black people
coming from and other races coming from
so then that's what i was trying to get
down to is he's already showing i
haven't even he said in the video i
think he said i haven't had a problem
with black people i've had more problems
with white people but there's still this
stigma of this racism so obviously it
boils down to something and i feel like
as a generation the more we talk about
it the more that it will be excluded
because we see it's wrong and if you
look at it today i feel like in any
point in time in history especially here
in america you know racism is going down
more and more and more as the new
generation sees
don't you think he was able to
i mean his message to you because he
knows he's on camera was very scaled
back right like if you had a hidden
camera on him and his homie talking
about black people or jews or whatever
it would have been a lot more vile so in
a way he did some he was able to do some
nice pr on camera for you and also i
will say at one point that really kind
of took me back is when you guys ended
your conversation and you said is there
anything you want to say to the people
and he goes thanks for listening and i
was like oh damn that
that's kind of [ __ ] up that he got to
just like platform his his beliefs like
that that all being said
um i think the video is overall good and
i don't i'm not trying to say like ah
you [ __ ] up and the video is horrible
and you should never made it i think
what hassan was originally trying to do
was just you know level some some
criticism at your approach and i think
ultimately maybe you got a little
defensive about it but i understand that
as well
you know i got defensive about it me
personally i feel
me being upset about it was justified
but i should have took more time to you
know react to
his video and your video beforehand
where i can have all my points running
down where i can say it in a cohesive
manner and stuff but that's not what
happened you know i like to do live
reactions and you know i'm here i get it
me too no i got emotional and i said
that i feel like my you know how i feel
still stands but
uh i feel like now coming on here you
know i kind of got to flesh out more of
how i thought you know you're not racist
right
no no yeah yeah
but i don't understand i still don't
understand the the accusation of of me
being lit uh liberal like you were
exhibiting liberal racism so how i just
don't understand that because that's
that's pretty harsh thing to level
against someone
and um i feel that so i'm gonna tell you
why i think you were exhibiting liberal
racism yeah so
in the left side i feel you know they're
pretty strong allies with like you know
the black community blm
but you know i feel like especially the
entire black community what we're
starting to see
is especially around election time we're
more used for boats than it is for
actually helping our people
uh i think it was a george floyd bill
that was supposed to be signed after he
had died about police brutality and
everything but that bill to this day
still hasn't been signed but i think a
asian lives matter bill has been signed
by him and i feel also that uh some
lgbtq bill was signed by him but that
bill uh
it was around the george floyd era but
that bill to this day has yet to been
signed and how was that being a liberal
racist
so how you were being a liberal racist
is you know instead of you saying you
know if you would have said hey judeon
you know you didn't you gave him a
platform man you should attack this more
i see like you the way you said it there
cool but in the video uh there goes
judeon campaigning for uh the neo-nazis
and you know and you know what we call
that in the black community you probably
don't know what that is because you know
you're not in the black community but
basically uh a lot of other black people
had the same sentiment especially you
kind of call me uncle tom so like uncle
tom is someone i know what uncle tom is
yeah no i i yeah yeah yeah but so you're
like you were basically calling me an
uncle no but i think what all i i think
all me and hassan said was that you just
were
a little ill-equipped to handle that
delicate of a conversation that's it i
don't understand how that implies you're
an uncle tom so to speak or maybe i'm
missing maybe i'm missing but you know
that's the thing like you and hassan you
know no offense to y'all but you guys
stay in y'all studios and you talk about
it from afar and i think in hassan's
video he said he looks at the empirical
data but you know i'm pretty sure before
he reacted to that video he didn't even
know what harrison arkansas was but it's
just like you know where someone like me
like yeah you know i might not be as
smart as y'all you know what it is i
don't think it's about that first of all
i i wanted to go to the field where it
said it's the most racist town i put
myself at harm i put my film around harm
yeah but we went there and i feel like
we've brought something you know for the
world to see because that video you know
you see that video and
you say oh yeah you know the video i'm
talking about in question where the guy
has a blm sign and it says and everybody
was calling him the n-word lover and all
this stuff you know what i'm talking
about
uh was that in the video no it was the
video that inspired oh
like it was the original i definitely i
definitely agree that like the concept
and you going there was super brave not
knowing what to expect like i totally
agree that like the video premise is
interesting and you're super brave to go
there i just don't know that
again i just don't know
that i understand still yet the liberal
racism so the liberal racism part is you
know
it feels you know you're a white man
telling me
oh judeo doesn't understand like this
racism he doesn't really quite
understand he was ill-prepared he was
unequipped he didn't know what he was
talking about you know he should have
been more prepared
it kind of sounds like you know
like whether you wanted to sound like
that or not like you should have been in
that situation because you could have
been better prepared for it
that's quite a that's a leap i don't
think so i definitely not i definitely
am not equipped to have that
conversation as a you know as a jewish
person that's not my
my thing i think obviously you're you're
but then but you gave an opinion on me
being unequipped for it
let me ask you this
is it possible
is it possible for a black person to not
be equipped for that conversation are
they all just perfectly equipped by the
nature of being a black american
it's not a fact about me being equipped
or not it's the fact that me wanted to
have the conversation so am i not
allowed to point that out without being
a racist
uh no
you can point out anything you want and
i have the right to
disagree with anything you say there was
a black man um i don't know if you know
about this he
would go to clan rallies
and he would literally
watch them do their burning of the
crosses he would talk to them and
eventually the white man he was talking
to eventually realized wow what i'm
doing is wrong
and he actually left being a nazi and he
brought a lot of other people with him
and so it's like you know it'll be the
same thing if you told that black man
when he went and the thing about that
black man he wouldn't even go there
disagreeing with them he literally did
the same thing i did he went there just
to hear what they had to say and
eventually when you talk to someone and
you just keep on spewing what you
believe and they don't retaliate or give
you their opinion but they just listen
then you realize wow what i'm saying is
kind of [ __ ] up i know you're pretty
sure i'm pretty sure i know the guy yeah
daryl davis yeah he's super interesting
what's the difference between what he
did and what i did
well what well if you want first of all
he didn't record it and put it on
youtube but that but but he made a
documentary about it yeah but also he
well he spent a lot of time building a
relationship with these people right and
speaking off-camera speaking candidly
with them i mean if you really want to
know what's the difference i mean you
had one short conversation with this guy
in which he said you can't come to my
church and he even was unwilling to
shake your hand and basically turned
around so like oh actually i shook his
hand you did okay i shook his hand so
but anyway i mean obviously he developed
a deeper relationship with them because
like you said clearly you're not
changing their mind in any way which
it's very difficult to do i mean they're
so entrenched in their ideology but what
you did and what he did is very
different no so i guess the only
difference is he changed his mind
because he had more time to be with them
and i didn't
potentially i mean i don't know about
his his approaches but uh he'd certainly
had a a lot more time to build the
relationships and have candid
conversations about it off camera so
would you say he was more prepared like
yeah yeah
yeah definitely but what was he more
prepared with besides the fact because
obviously he had more time with them so
how can i not be getting prepared for
that you know what if i go back there
and i get to talk to him again
that'd be great
but would i still be unprepared i don't
know i don't know what kind of prep i
don't know i mean look you're you're a
young man you know i know that guy who
did that was like older he had been
through a lot of [ __ ]
so i think i i i don't know what
preparation necessarily looks like i
would assume it's more
about yeah being prepared being prepared
to you know
respond to whatever they're talking you
got to be
prepared for they have logical fallacies
that they say they and stuff just be a
matter of being prepared to have that
dialogue and knowing like what's the
best way to
neutralize or or cut through uh
logical fallacies and stuff like that
and world ex and i think experience too
as a human being just being able to like
connect with people on a deep empathetic
level that you get from age frankly but
i'm not saying you know i'm not saying
it's impossible for a young man to do it
either i'm not i mean you know i'm not a
debater like you you and hassan you guys
not really
okay well hassan yeah makes his living
off of being a debater and everything
i'm not a debater i'm more of uh you
know obviously a prankster but i wanted
to show a different side of me and i
feel like that video really did show a
different side of me where yeah i showed
more of my interviewing skills more of
you know me less of the trolling and
more of me just asking the questions you
know like nico did the same video and he
actually got to talk to the leader of
the kkk
but you know
i don't see i agree man there's nothing
wrong with it but do you find it ironic
to on one hand call me a liberal racist
for
criticizing your preparedness
uh to have that conversation while doing
a nazi hitler salute in front of a kkk
building
i mean you know it's ironic it is a
black a black man doing that it's like
the same thing with the context of you
saying the f word and the n word
multiple time on idubbbz stream you know
yeah were you seeing it out of racism
yes or no
uh no no no so obviously so you're
getting that out of racism so what what
is the context
the context is
a black guy at a kkk
camp where he shouldn't be
throwing up their salute obviously i'm
being
i'm just joking around not joking around
about the situation
the fact that nazis really funny black
people that much i think they they did
oh
yeah i thought the nazis yeah okay if
you weren't if you wanted the aryan race
they didn't like you
yeah because i remember they like hitler
was obsessed with like that olympian
well he thinks he jews were at the very
bottom of the totem pole but he had a
whole totem pole and black people were
pretty far down there too anybody that
wasn't blonde blue eyed yeah basically
uh was
lower a lower person so
okay so this is uh
[Music]
okay cool
yeah but i just want to come on here
like you know what i feel like
i didn't you know
really display my true feelings so i
hope you know my true feelings now you
know i'm not expecting an apology or
anything like that but like this is
exactly what i want to do it's like yeah
having the conversation instead of us
having a beef on twitter for years
and you know doing the l3l3 because i
don't know if you know this but i
actually grew up on you you know
national like i grew up on youtube
yeah a lot of my uh career and
everything so you tweeted out like two
days ago i missed the old h3 what does
that mean
oh man bro you know we missed the old h3
where you and hilo uh gila right is that
how you pronounce it yeah where you guys
would just sit down react to videos make
comedy sketches
you know you know the old h3 the h3 that
was trying to uh raise a bunch of money
for to fight a lawsuit battle i remember
actually i was trying to donate my first
paycheck to you because around this time
you're uh
uh raising money for your i forgot to do
his name but uh like hoffman yeah
yeah
that's awesome i appreciate that i think
yeah but you you reached the goal way
before i could even send in that
paycheck and stuff so that's the old h3
i'm talking about but it seems like when
people say that it's more like country
detractors who are like i don't like
what he's become now so i guess i'm
curious what is it that i do that you
don't like these days just to give you
an opportunity to talk about it because
it's not it's not necessarily that i
don't like what you do now it's just me
personally you like the old stuff i like
the old stuff you know sometimes we
think of the hey that you know people
are going to say the same thing about me
people going to be like oh man i missed
the old judeon and i understand you know
we have to grow up and everything and
you know i feel like you maybe took a
turn
further off the road than most people do
with their careers but hey it's working
you know you have a successful brand for
you you have people like dan w employees
in the chat yeah
definitely dubs
appreciate it i can't hate on you like
that you know you got a beautiful family
and everything so
you know i'm not gonna hate on you for
that you know but you know just shouting
out the old h3h3 members you know so it
was like it was like a shout out to
being like yo this guy's all content
rules but i don't remember the old days
yeah it's like remember the old days
yeah yeah
so anyway but ultimately i want to wrap
it up and say
you know i don't it's not like i hated
the video or even that i had very strong
opinions about it i think it just turned
into this back and forth that kind of
turned interesting and then
the
the orangutan thing was kind of nuts so
but i'm glad we could talk it out for
you yeah wow yeah yeah i'm gonna get all
matthew for that but also if you go on
my community tabs on my second channel
you'll see like three or four months ago
yeah i posted one thumbnail i was like
bro sorry we have to delete that other
thumbnail because matthew was willing
what was it
oh man i forget but he's a 17 year old
you know i hired him he's good i mean
yeah i like i like that that he
expresses himself a little bit there but
i guess sometimes you you take it too
far i clicked that [ __ ]
i was like i said what
[Laughter]
you said about uh you know i gotta um be
more around so you know before things go
up you know i'm gonna take criticism
where criticism is due i'm gonna you
know make sure when before things go out
so if it's not on my part i can snip it
in the bud so situations like this don't
happen and you know i'm not gonna tell
you what to do because this is obviously
your business but i would just say going
in the future especially talking about
issues like regarding other races
uh i would say maybe more have
more self-awareness of like what you're
saying because you got to realize
different races have different fights
they're going against because obviously
you talk about so many different topics
so obviously you're going to end up
talking about different races so i would
just say
more of have like a look on okay
what could this race be going through at
a time where
you know could my comments maybe offend
someone or offend us this race and i
would say if you go in with that
more forethought because what you said
here if you would have said that in your
video i would have not said anything it
would have been like you know what fair
point you know i could see that but
maybe next time next interview i can
inject more interject more and you know
be like okay guys you know don't listen
to that part but you know you didn't
give me room to make corrections for the
future you more have just made a
statement that low-key i felt patron was
patronizing but you know what i feel
like we squashed it off here and i know
there's no hard feelings no there's no
hard feelings i never did i like you i
think you're funny i think you're
talented and i think you have a right
that means a lot but just just so you
know like when i said the n-word that
was wrong right like i apologize for
that and i've learned a lot and then and
that's something that i would never do
now
and um
i hope you know that about the nazi
salute as well
yeah and you know what even in the
context of uh you're jewish so i
apologize if that offended you and you
know i was hoping that it was just
pretty well known that it was ironic but
you know it seemed to take offense to
you so since it took offense for you
well qualified
so i appreciate you apologizing and i
apologize on mine as well there you go
beautiful
well i i appreciate you being mature and
calling in
and uh saying what up and yeah you know
i don't like these you
and you know i saw you gotten in trouble
with with some pokey stuff and you guys
squashed the beef i thought that was
cool too
but again yeah i just i it's not it's
not like a heavy criticism you know it's
just some some comments but i i
understand it's all good i understand
getting uh
feeling patronized as well so it's all
good i apologize
i appreciate that ethan thank you
what
oh yeah i apologize
appreciate you thank you
anyway
thank you bro appreciate you calling in
everybody in the chat
w podcast wstream right now
you guys can still call me la dion it's
all good no we've been calling you
william today
on okay
all right love you dan
thanks bro
dan became the
hero the hero we don't deserve
but i just actually i wasn't sure what i
was i just and i don't mean to be
offensive i just i i think it's more of
like
that he's young and if you were if you
felt like he was being uh
too targeted
you apologized that he felt that way
because i guess you've been there i
guess i just i don't like to make him
feel bad yeah you know
but
i don't think i was exhibiting
liberal rights no no
i mean but i mean listen he's a sweet
guy
i do like him it was awesome that he
called in i don't know
how that conversation went frankly
uh but
it's over now
how did that go do you guys think be
honest
i think it was good
i think it's always good to talk i
thought it was oh yeah i mean it went
well no i think we got a little bit more
to
cut to what his intentions with that
video are i mean
ultimately
we don't have to agree on whether it was
a good idea or not to have the
conversation but you know you
acknowledged that you felt like he had
good intentions he clarified that he
does not support anything that that guy
says you know it it i think from his
mindset he
wanted to just have the conversation so
people could hear for themselves
what this person believes um and you
know it's kind of like giving them the
rope so that i mean and that's that's
that's how louis thoreau does his
interviewing style he calls it radical
listening sure where he lets people kind
of just expose themselves or even like
andrew uh from channel 5
as well um
and yeah you know
i think ultimately
i i don't necessarily agree that you
were exhibiting this but what he brought
up about you know the liberal racism
thing boiling down to
um
people in the democratic party
using i agree but i don't know why not
actually supporting them
legislatively that's a legitimate
grievance i agree but like it's weird to
bring it doesn't seem fair to me to
bring that up and then as a point to
talk about how i'm a liberal racist i
don't think that just seems like a
disingenuous segue
i don't know if so i don't know if it's
disingenuous i i do agree that it's just
what's it got to do with me it's it's a
stretch for sure but what is the [ __ ]
the democrats not doing more for black
americans got to do it to me um
yeah well i think you know his feelings
about that may have just spilled over
into feeling like what you were doing
was also being condescending because you
know he obviously has that opinion that
he feels like liberals are condescending
to black people um i agree with you that
i don't think it really applied in the
case of what you said but i think that's
probably where that's coming from
yeah
but you know what
i do like the guy and it was cool that
he called him that's it god bless it got
a lot it got a little more serious than
i expected
you know
i figured it would go there but you know
thank you can edim for 20 gifted
suburinos i would say the beef is
squashed for sure and to be honest uh
the thing that i was really tipped off
was that thumbnail and he changed it so
that's good there you go yeah what's
that guy's name matthew matthew shut up
matthew you're a [ __ ] yeah
at the savage yeah
you to be careful with those text
bubbles bro because
the text bubble means literal [ __ ]
saying this right [ __ ] savage you
gotta do it you gotta be careful with
that one he can maybe change it again
the new one would the new one is not
good
the new one is not no me is just a
little bit more confusing
but i know like offensive yeah yeah yeah
sure what what the goal is i think he's
trying to make it sound like oh look at
this smart black person like i'm saying
ironically yeah look at him act like an
educated african-american implying that
i don't believe amer african-americans
would be educated
he shapes it again by the way okay
what's the neuron where are we at now
yeah round three
this one's fine hold on
here we go
all right let's see what we got the new
one
drum roll please
here we go
it says he's worse than freaking prank
invasion now i didn't say that either
not even close man
not even close
at least it's not me saying something
racist right yeah it's about let me make
out i'll settle for that definitely not
worse than prank conversion prank
conventions
no
worse than prank amazing
but okay i i'll accept this one just
because yeah you know what i'm saying
you got to be careful with those text
bubbles bro i'm just saying i'm saying
all right
lydian
beef squashed when
there's a lot of text bubbles in on that
channel that makes me wonder if that's
actually in the video or not
dude it's almost certainly not
if he did it to me like what's this one
say
don't make me spank your big baboon butt
again bro stop
yeah i don't know
you can't do that because that's that's
like you're putting all the weirdness no
we didn't say that
there's no way that this best buy
employee told him i'm going to spank
your baboon butt again no way
and what's crazy is he's putting out
super racist
he's the one putting those super racist
tropes out like that's me doing a text
bubble of me like walking through best
buy
burning of oven you dirty jewish [ __ ] or
monsters
come on dude
you can't i don't know uh i i shouldn't
say i'm going to say something i don't i
i probably oops
oh god i said the c word but i kind of
stomped myself midway so maybe it's fine
maybe it's okay
thank you can i get a saudi please yeah
thank you all right what was it that i
said
you you sons of [ __ ]
no
no
anyway
all right we got plenty to do that was
an unexpected uh that was a little
detour yeah yeah to have the
conversation though
w dan if you guys have any more of these
though i'd like to see them these are
pretty crazy
love that
oh there's more
so
gosh where were we uh i apologize to the
cats
we were gonna do the game with the
parents okay there's one other thing
before the game okay
super interested in this guy's theory
pete
you know we've joked about the red line
green line theory
it's not a theory it's a fact yeah yeah
it's this well like evolutions of theory
never be a beta check this out this
guy's on to something up after nine
months yet another reminder that the
green lines they never lie i actually
introduced the green light theory to
tick-tock through this photo of pete and
kent in that tic-tac-toe he introduced
it and pete weren't gonna lie
pete
no this guy's been going on about this
for a minute he is the real deal he's a
modern day sigmund freud thank you
so here
whatever but kim was never going to
respect a leaner like pete but yeah the
green lines they never lie
they never lie pete is a multiple time
offender of leaning in that green line
he's cheating on that one into pete
that's not a legitimate
leaning into pete there was one in there
that it was like
that green line was crooked but he was
standing straight up like he was he was
fudging are you thinking
yes
let's take another look
when where they're on the red carpet
oh [ __ ] he is not bent over that oh
look at his top but i think the green
line goes through the tie i think
straight up
i think what he means
is that he is
the one exerting an action or something
on her leaning into her in some way
the line could make like here's the
straight line it could be like
it could be like this but he has it like
this he's not standing like that he
definitely embellished it what does the
green dot mean here
i think
uh mistake
typo i wasn't sure how polished his
videos were decoration
yeah but um
here's one oh see
bro this man look at this here's one of
kim leaning into pete same night that's
the same night and that's a huge green
line violation right
just saying i'm busting this theory wide
open he's way taller than her i mean
come on
wow and look at this work and that's
good posture that's straight up boy
it's a good pick
yeah have you made any moves yet olivia
on uh getting a hold of him i mean he is
he's so out of
he's way far gone i think he's he is
unattainable what what
don't i don't want
you can you imagine first of all
unattainable however can you imagine
dating someone right after kim
kardashian dated them
you'd be a step up
you better hush
never say that
people know how i feel about kim on the
show so that is true i'm just saying
there's a chance i'll take it as you
just see me very you see me very highly
yeah thank you no i do mean that and
look look i don't want to scare you but
you look behind you cut to olivia again
wait a minute
he's here
where did that come from is he still
your fave celebrity crush though um
i mean sure but like he's everybody's
now i need to find something new
and something fresh sam is here do you
agree that he's the hottest thing
no we just agree on
he's a very i feel like he's a very
specific type he is we both use
jack
sam and i both love jack
who's jack
harlow jack harwood are you both and you
really how dare you like the sex icon
yeah we meet in the middle with jack
harlow i don't know about sex icon well
i do he's very charming isn't that what
we're talking about
hey get that off of the screen it's a
camera and who am i leaning into i'm
just l life
beta what about
yeah you'd do this sex icon this is
pretty dope [ __ ] eating buckets of
kfc
[ __ ] that's a lot of chicken for
one man
looks awesome
[ __ ] fried chicken
so who's your ideal guy sam
ian oh come on
[Applause]
uh mitchell
morrison
100 bucks says love's kfc fund
chicken chicken oh interesting that you
sent that one
well i sent it i didn't send it up until
we were talking about kfc okay true true
it was appropriate
yeah
who's your guys do you would you guys
say who's your celebrity crush i'll be
honest i don't really have one
nowadays you look like
well yeah ella cline is a celebrity it's
true she's [ __ ] that doesn't that
does count she's hot as [ __ ] dude for
reals bro
she slays those fits every
it's crazy allison white is a little bit
of a celebrity in certain
art twitter circles all right you guys
are just cheating you guys aren't
playing fun you're just naming your
significant other ryan gosling
yeah you want to [ __ ] ryan gosling oh
yeah true i don't want to [ __ ] him i'm
just saying he [ __ ]
who does he [ __ ]
you no he just fought exactly [ __ ] you
no i don't want him to [ __ ] me i'm just
saying he [ __ ]
we had the debate yesterday i think brad
pitt [ __ ] more than ryan gosling brad
pitt [ __ ] but not harder dude brad pitt
is such a dude that guy is
if you look at like his old pic he's
still super handsome but
he's a [ __ ] [ __ ] for how
good-looking he is
it's like it's like why the [ __ ] do
i have to share
the space
with this guy
i mean i'm happily married and stuff but
like how am i how is anyone else
supposed to get chicks mm-hmm that's
just [ __ ] stupid no god gave just god
gave with two hands when they made him
stupid bro there's a lot of celebs that
like girls like that i'm like i don't
understand what it is but him can't
argue
take me he's a handsome fake me look at
this he's a handsome feller come on dude
type in uh brad pitt long hair
now he really [ __ ] that no no brad
pitt fight club like tyler nerd in there
and tyler that's let's see i want to see
zach's idea like look at that girl i
gotta say that
for me the long hair doesn't matter for
me really well we know zackson dude i'm
telling you white club yeah it does have
beautiful hair though like look at it
look at this look at the hair he's got
it all like he's got this perfect face
and then he has beautiful hair too and
i'll say a really good hairline
fantastic
jesus good great jawline i mean didn't
he just there's some story about him
from angelina e harmony just said brad
pitt is my second cousin shout out to
your family eharmony is that right
second cousin
shout out to your family
i'm seeing a lot of
brad pitt's kind of mid in the chat no
you guys are just saying that to be
contrarian look no one will reign higher
than the goss in my eyes
beautiful dude brad pitt is way better
looking than he's not mine
like in that in that golden era in the
photos of like him johnny and
leo yeah i gravitate more towards
aaliyah a young leo or a young johnny
ila likes leo by the way
she always tells me that's her celebrity
crush young leo
who doesn't and i'm like i'm like dude
how the [ __ ] am i supposed to compete
with this [ __ ] like
what if i just go
like gilbert grape leo
well i don't know
maybe this is too young
young i don't know it's like it's
titanic leo the one right there with the
cigarette in the middle that's the one
oh jack leo jack dog
baby no that haircut is just like wow he
is a kid yeah doesn't he
oh he's like super young when they made
that movie
what gilbert grape
no titanic titanic i think he was like
in his 20s here i'll say leah or say
leonardo
and why she got a name like a ninja
turtle
leonardo dicaprio 20s just to add to the
sexy points
he was 21 when they started filming
titanic
i can't find like i guess here i don't
know
look at that haircut man they all have
this beautiful [ __ ] hair that's what
pissed me off the most
you're the hairline king though no but
my hair sucks dude look at that dude
straight perfect [ __ ] edges
curves
somebody donated twenty dollars for
cam's chinchilla fund guys
we need to
we gotta figure out a new fund this is
not it's not very difficult
let me just explain when
when the whole sam jeep thing happened
last week
it created like a lot of work like post
post
show work for me uh to compile all of
that because it really wasn't easy i've
now i've i've set up a tool that all the
super chats now gets saved in a
spreadsheet so that makes it easier but
it still comes in in like different
currencies so like i was having to do
like
gather up all the british pounds and
then gather up all the canadian dollars
gather up all the swedish crones and
then like do conversions it's
there's got to be a better way than the
super chat to work on these funds that
you said thank you very much now that
you said that everybody's going to be
donating money chaotically
and it's going to be i don't know it's
gonna be
how about you take a cut from all of it
oh that's interesting oh you skim a
little off the top
dude you deserve it just embezzled
something
yeah
what do you guys think is a fair rate
for dan what's it good
ten percent and what do i get where's my
cut
20.
zero well youtube takes thirty i take
ten and even takes twenty yeah i'm not
thinking i'm just kidding but dan you
should take ten percent off the top bro
that'd be epic five percent build
something for your time no i want people
to get uh no i would never
thank you ten percent
you've earned it
listen done
you've worked hard for this organization
you deserve a little bit of uh well
people saying five percent
five percent
[Music]
about two five percent together it's ten
percent
five percent difference is astronomical
donated five and said sorry dan i mean
to upset you it's it's not upsetting me
but i just wanted to like
put that information out there that it
it actually is kind of a
pain in the ass to do these these funds
so i don't know who's the guy who played
bain in batman uh party tom hardy yeah
that guy
i think
i think that guy [ __ ]
yeah also he's like such a good actor
and he always looks so different but
he's kind of
he's very [ __ ]
i mean he got yoked when he was playing
bain
like [ __ ] and he was so yolked
that one show the uh
peeky blinders yeah peaky blinders so
good i love that
yeah he played a jew i was like man
ain't no jew's that handsome sup
he had like a seed curls and [ __ ] but he
looked like a supermarket
nah
no [ __ ] shot
by the way cultural appropriation
no there's no shot that man is doing
already this article says hardy of
course is about as jewish as bacon so
yeah
okay you didn't have to put it like that
yeah it's from a jewish magazine that
couldn't you find a jew to play this
culture appropriation much
alfie salomon no i don't care he was
amazing in this role so good
so he does have that weird chameleon
thing i feel like everything he did and
it's a different dude yeah he's such a
good actor
am i alone in this isn't tom hardy the
most [ __ ]
uh
i think he's nobody backing me up i
don't think he has the same factor that
ben and uh our brad and leo have
something's missing yeah yeah yeah he's
not quite on that level
yeah and i don't think oh go ahead you
ever see tom hardy's myspace photos
no
let's go
as they're not not safe for work are
they um
screaming take off the screen uh yeah
take off yeah all right let's see tom
hardy final call
what the [ __ ] is this who is this
there's your boy
what the [ __ ] is this photo
this a goof
that's a yeah he was like a goofball on
myspace i don't know
that's lon hardy here he is you can show
this
my boy
what the [ __ ] my man looking good on
myspace
well
i missed those myspace guys
i'm the only one huh tom hardy fan
no i'm seeing support for the tom hardy
in the chat i just uh
like they said i just don't think he
quite
rises to that level of uh
some of the other ones we've named
but he definitely [ __ ]
yeah we were having this
a similar debate here at the [ __ ]
i mean that's true
yeah
so what does that mean for me
dude do i [ __ ] it's not like a
physical like
intercourse does ethan [ __ ] you you do
[ __ ] yeah you're a baller okay you [ __ ]
i have had sex i'm not a virgin but that
that has nothing that has nothing to do
with intercourse it's really nothing
it's it's nothing
any type of intercourse it's whether you
[ __ ] okay i'm just clarifying but you do
[ __ ] yes
thanks bro whatever that means
tom hardy used to be a male escort he
used myspace to advertise is
all actually true i missed my
opportunity the message says this is all
actually true so it must be
wow
i wonder how much it costs for that
a lot of uh
robert pattinson love in the chat i
think he is
he is the next gen like
90s leo or brad pitt i think i endorse
that he's like one of the only i like
him i don't think he has that classic
beauty
sammy you agreeing with me he has that
classic beauty boys boys will be boys
look at me and tom hardy dogs for life
[Applause]
let me sneak in let me get one last
escorting thing
just one more bro
people saying henry cavill i mean he's
too beautiful he's everything you were
saying about brad pitt kind of applies
to him he's too jack he's way too like
good-looking yeah someone in the chat
said some of these guys are too manly
and then like leo and brad are beautiful
right they got that perfect there's
almost
there's
timothy yeah i think he could be a big
one yeah i gotta i gotta occur but miles
teller
all right who's that uh austin butler i
guess is like riding a wave right now
too he played a rooster in uh
uh
team edward all day
it's not dude he's handsome fine he's
handsome it's not happening miles he's
not edward handsome nice yeah he was in
whiplash too
he's got like a he went crazy on the
drums yeah so but you guys think robert
pattison is like
i don't know he just he doesn't have a
face
that
well here's the thing i don't know like
leo like a lot of people like him
besides his looks was his character and
the titanic and then rob patterson
playing uh edward i think contributes a
lot to uh
the baseball twilight movies sexiness
thank you zach people throwing out
michael b jordan
that's what i said yes yesterday when we
were talking about this yesterday he did
come up and yeah he is
extremely good looking too i think the
michael b jordan wants a trip because
i'm a huge fan of the wire right and in
that show he was a kid and he played
like a dorky
gangly skinny
uh
nerdy dude who's just like a punk
and
i didn't realize it was the same person
until like look at this he was like
super skinny dorky kid
he's a great actor by the way even back
right now i mean he was so good in this
show
but i was like holy [ __ ] that's the kid
from the wire yeah but no michael
jordan's he's good he's cool
i feel like he hasn't come into his own
with the star power yet though
like all he really had i just pulled up
his credits and it's like he's done the
creed movies which were hits
and then he was the bad guy in black
panther
yeah i think the black panther one was
so big though i mean that was huge for
sure
but he needs like
his own
um
superhero role or something he was
people's sexiest man of the year a few
years ago
apollo i mean that could be his big
heart dude the creed movies were big
listen guys get inspired this kid did
some push-ups and and became the sexiest
man in the world
like just get inspired you know time to
start doing some push-ups yeah that's a
glow-up [ __ ]
anyway all right another tangent he was
fantastic in creed i mean really good
role
people are have lots of ideas in the
chat
about who's the
oh silly and murphy i like him
the thing with him i think he's really
good looking personally but i know a lot
of people with him it's like people
really really like him or they don't see
it no who doesn't see that who is that
this guy from peaky blinders oh yeah uh
scarecrow yeah scarecrow okay
who doesn't see that
i don't know just a lot of people i've
heard say that he's got like another
perfect face situation
no he's a good looking dude i mean his
he's got very he's kind of gaunt yeah i
don't think everybody's into that look
yeah that probably works against him as
is being kind of universally seen that
way yeah i agree he's handsome though
i've seen better pictures look at this
one
yeah i've heard girls say that it's too
perfect
oh stop it i'm just saying what i've
heard i think it's the blue eyes that
are just blue eye perfect cheekbones
lips nose everything it's like
sculpted by the gods yeah
or maybe just as tommy shelby that's
what girls are obsessed with that's true
like so the bad boy yeah i think more
into the character because he is cute as
tommy shelby but
like other pictures of him i think he's
just ordinary
right he did yeah he was badass in that
show you do like the bad boy don't you
lena that's like what abe is with his
musk i'm a fan of tommy shelby yeah oh
okay
he asked you about me lena
you are kind of a bad boy the aesthetic
is bad
you too abe you know that do you agree
that aby's aesthetic is bad boy
um yeah bad boy with a heart attack
people would describe him that way but
he wouldn't say that about himself no
but he's got the tats he's got the car
you've got a mustang bro challenger
challenger whatever the [ __ ]
you have a bad boy car
bad boy bad boy what you got you're a
bad boy
certified baddie all right shout out
all right enough of that
carrot top will always be my heart
[Laughter]
i love me a muscular carrot top
that's everything to me look at this
it's sculpted by the gods
somebody zachary donated twenty dollars
said young norm mcdonald is the most
beautiful man and i'm not even gay pull
it up
okay
look at carrot
[Laughter]
you know who's also really good looking
is the dude that played hopper
on stranger things yeah yeah yeah oh his
name has been david harbor yeah he's a
good looking dude sam i heard i heard
that's why sam made ian grow a mustache
oh is that why oh
yo okay he is actually okay or
mcdonald's way more handsome than i
would have expected
okay ian show your mustache is that why
sam
show me your mustache you a hopper girl
is that wise the mustache was miles
she's a hopper girl hopping on this dick
oh
[ __ ] my mom's watching today
[Laughter]
no ian show your mustache i did yeah
yeah
you did oh you did yeah sorry yeah
yes i don't want to out my co-workers
but both him and zach watched top gun
and came back with those mustaches
what's wrong with that dude exactly
what is wrong with that i let it
marinate a little bit
like i didn't do it immediately to try
and throw people off the trail but yeah
you got a mean stash let me get let me
take a look at that you mean it's pretty
grown in it's quite good in rocky it's
almost like old-timey it's like an
old-timey stash
sam's been getting on my case about it
lately i don't know why it's very uh
it's very cop i'm not gonna lie which i
guess goes to the hopper theory
you're a fan of his stash sam
i yeah i like it
[Laughter]
ali has been
telling me to have a mustache for pretty
much as long as he's been dating and i
mean i'm sitting my bad boyfriend
because i've i've pretty much just
flatly said no that's not how you're not
gonna do it i don't i would like to see
no offense no offense to those rocking
the stash in here personally not a fan
of the aesthetic not a fan of that i'm
just kind of surprised the mustache is
making a comeback apparently it is maybe
it's you ethan i i think you brought it
back
no it's been a minute since i've been
doing it
yeah yeah yeah no it's been a minute
since since you've been doing it well my
dad has had a mustache his whole life
the gary stash is quite yeah
it's iconic powerful i shaved i shaved
my mustache for hawaiian shirt day and i
[ __ ] hated it but people people were
very kind everyone said cam looked cute
i disagree but i shaved it as soon as
the show ended that day too
yeah it feels a little weird at first if
you're not used to it but anyway moving
on
um
let's see
we got that oh so we got to talk about
david dobrik trying to kill another
friend
this man
is being sued he just can't negligently
ki trying to kill jeff
best friend by the way friend of the
show dubrick
and this [ __ ] this was on
snapchat was this even on tick tock or
did they remove it it was just on
snapchat yeah i'll check
maybe
i'm so confused by snapchat i don't
understand why it's still a thing
uh if you click the bottom right it will
unmute
so here is dubrover
[Music]
all right guys let's just oh wait let me
pull up the backup we have so i can go
frame by frame because her head
actually does set fire
which if you're david dobrik where you
are now after everything i mean
maybe not maybe not
maybe not
you
know okay a little bit more aggressive
so let's go frame by frame and you can
really see
her life i am your father harry that's
not from harry potter but remember when
i get you you have to die okay go say it
again i am your father harry incendio
okay so
look at that her hair is on fire bro
what even is this thing he david has
like
super high powered david has like this
fetish for like obscure weaponry it
shoots flash paper it's supposed to
imitate a harry potter wand and then it
like burns up real quick
really because it caught her on fire bro
look at this
right to her hair
this isn't like a custom
like thing it's not like widely sold by
the product it's been trending on tick
tock people have been showing it off and
like explaining how it works the video
is like officially licensed no it's not
no no no okay wait you can buy this [ __ ]
on amazon
you could buy i don't know if it's on
amazon but you could buy it online um
yeah so i don't know dude what the [ __ ]
bro stop this is like the third time
you've tried to kill natalie
she must really need a job
look our hair's still on fire
flames on her head
so we love that for him
ain't no fire's gonna come out that
butthole
by the way
obviously she's fine
but even in the moment of crisis after
everything he's been through they they
get scared because their hair's on fire
he just doesn't drop the camera
he keeps that camera rolling baby i'm
still laughing and laughs yeah
incendion
pretty impressive man the guy's staying
true to himself he's the joker you think
he's joker he is so joker brain man
he's praying at the joker church
listen he's saying true to himself most
people can't say that his what he's
staying true to himself is trying to
kill everyone around him the joker
church
so apparently you can buy this harry
potter wand
115 dollars
oh that's a good pr i mean hiring an
assassin is probably way more expensive
oh yeah
talking tens of thousands
also
something that just occurred to me if
the laser is powerful enough to ignite
hair
that seems powerful enough that it
should not be shown into people's eyes
it says do not point in people's faces
yeah which means
if this had gone slightly different he
would have taken out another eye
he was only a couple inches away from
right yeah
he's collecting eyes bro and that would
be the third eye he's taken out wait
what's the third
tell his friend he threw the pine cone
at it he needs one for the back of his
head he's like dexter morgan with
eyeballs whoa
trying to collect his third [ __ ] eye
how he's gonna be like little zebra he's
gonna have well his third eye and the
one on the back right that's gonna
unlock the power that's been constrained
within him he's like damien he's like a
when that third eye goes it's all of our
fault
you can't blame him anymore so true
we hope he's okay i'm curious about this
one though what is this thing
it's a third eye blind
yeah my favorite band would have been
third time blind
oh [ __ ] that's the elder one
the thing is no joke
no
that just seems like a terrible idea
like it doesn't even look cool it's just
a terrible idea just shooting fire at
somebody
mean also that's what you use a wand for
you shoot someone
so
so there you have it
there it is huh
congratulations oh it's not oh
wait i don't think it is a laser no it
shoots some kind of fire paper
like a little spit ball of fire
david okay david is youtube's jigsaw
from chat that is funny
i don't know if that makes it that's
better so funny because he also gives
them prizes if they win
right
would you like to play a
game sorry
yes so there's that
which is fun we love that
one more eye for the legend
i guess let's play who's your daddy and
what does he do
who is my daddy what does he do
this is the game that everybody's been
waiting for
who is your daddy and what does he do
folks we have collected
pictures of every person's parents
yes
so
just in case you haven't noticed there's
an album
separate from what i have on screen
right now so that you can take a closer
look at the pictures
i've got it right here thank you
and um
it will be my job
to look closely at these photos and
determine whose
parents are these i'm looking at daddy
and what does he do so how do you want
to do this i'll start with the photos
on the top
uh do you have access to the number of
ones i'm showing or can you show these
yeah we can
we can as you're looking through them
you can show them this chart
just to be clear is so that we can uh
assign your picks all these moves so you
would you know say i think this person
is this parent so i and then i put them
dude i know whose parent this is it's
obviously olivia's mom
right
or could it be sam's mom
interesting hmm
this is interesting isn't
it ah [ __ ]
i think it's olivia's mom
okay what do you think about that
what do i think about it yeah
i can't tell you anything obviously
beautiful woman
oh so you want me to go by crew member i
think it might be easier well i mean so
i don't look through them though right
by the way so just as you go
i can kind of move them into where you
think and you can change your mind and
we'll so let's put this let's put this
uh beautiful
uh woman on
olivia's tab here got it i'm gonna watch
chat too like price is right sometimes
they okay shout the answer
okay
um moving on now who is this slick
that's a lovely dad
a nice dad
uh
uh is that dan's dad
[Music]
not okay so put this this is not
ian's or
abs or zacks
orlinas
it could be olivia's dad
this one i thought was the easiest one i
was looking through who is my daddy and
what does he do
i'm gonna say dan i guess for now
when dan
people are saying oh wait love's in here
i forgot yeah okay wait
i'm seeing lots of loves in chat you
know i forgot about love
sorry love i think this is your dad
who's love
who
stop it
all right i have thrown it over to love
very interesting love how do you feel
about that
you can't ask people i know i'm testing
you guys
[Music]
i wonder whose mom this could be
there's basically two options right i
mean
there's lena what's so [ __ ] funny
zach
i've never seen that woman in my life
okay so is this a b well wait your mom
your mom's white
see
well that narrows it down
this is his mom actually i see the
resemblance
uh shout out to lina's mom here
it's gotta be
thank you
yeah she looks just like you actually
alina
eyebrows you guys have the same eyebrows
yeah i guess since it's a kind of a
giveaway everyone says that i'm her twin
you guys have good eyebrow game just to
say oh thank you matt crazy eyebrow game
thank you i know a lot about eyebrow
game because ela has a good eyebrow game
and i hear that all the time right so i
know i respect the good eyebrow
moving on that was actually dan's mom by
the way
by the way this is literally zach
that's just zach isn't that crazy though
like
that's [ __ ] hilarious he looks just
like no it's very bizarre but the thing
is i don't look like my dad when he was
younger i look like my dad when he like
hit puberty and matured how old is he in
this photo [ __ ] uh he he might be my age
yeah early 20s yeah you guys both have
that glowing red cheek yep
sweet
young men long beautiful hair i i just
particularly love his like
his um
his fro he's got going on like yeah it's
interesting a jew froze his perm more of
like a jew mullet yeah exactly
yeah
but yeah
it's so funny
are you becoming todd zach
i mean we look alike i mean i have
looked like him my whole life even when
i was a kid and what's wild is zach's
brother looks exactly like zach as well
and so all the men in the family is just
strong jeans yeah clones you're todd
betty yeah
shout out todd
beautiful young man
love that for him
that's awesome
it's just you
i know it's weird okay this is an
interesting one
it's like an actress famous actress over
here beautiful woman
i mean i'm getting sam vibes
getting sam vibes
but there's a lot of options at this
moment
[Music]
what do you guys think about this one
kate bush she does just look like kate
bush on sam
[Music]
sorry a little bit thank you
testing you
some people are saying cam okay that's
interesting
hmm
cam or sam or ian i don't know what
ian's mom looks like
[ __ ] you don't really know what any of
her moms look like
this is a tough one or people are saying
dan as well oh god i don't know where to
take this one hmm
i know
sam's mom's a southern
belle right
um
no she's not she's not from the south
but she lives there currently
[ __ ]
and the answers are all over the place
in chat you guys are not helping me at
all you're just spamming everybody's
name
i'm even seeing lena's see love
ian all right
i i my gut my instinct was sam
because i i don't know there's just
you guys are no help in the chat sam
temple think of the gifted sub think of
a gifted
oh this is interesting wow who's this
wow
that's cam's dad
it's gotta be right who is my daddy
looking dapper having a nice coffee
is something in the eyes
that's like exactly cam
you're smiling though is that your daddy
um what do you guys think actually mine
yeah you're dead again
they're all they're all
they're all three sam's dead
every single parent is throat
uh cam i'm feeling camp some people are
saying sam
yeah i'm gonna go cam i see cam in this
face i just do
i see sam
well you
you you don't know the answer no i don't
you see sam a little bit i don't i don't
know that i see cameron's face there
dude
wait cut three
yeah cut to cam
oh you know what it is they have this
they have the same glasses wait wait i
can't see what you pulled up
oh it's good here
i see olivia
oh i see olivia too oh [ __ ] now you guys
really got me confused
i gotta go with my gut
uh cam cam cam okay i'm throwing it on
cam camily emily
who is this uh
beautiful young woman
eating
a swedish snack
[Music]
i was like what does that say for y'all
you're good
i actually didn't think of that dude
your mom is beautiful
how old is she in this photo
probably like 23 like one that is just
as she before she i wonder if that's
right before i was born like a year
before somewhere
was she eating a salami
yes salami
we tried to get photos around the time
we were born
right for everyone
okay well that's love's uh mom we love
her yeah she was very young when i where
she goes
[Music]
oh she had you young
yeah 24. that's cool i get maybe that's
not super young i don't know no it's
that's young
my mom was 19. well there you have it
who the [ __ ] are you
who is that
hmm
[Music]
that is interesting isn't it
i'm seeing a little bit of olivia
i'm getting super strong vibes from this
one i don't know who that is you can
tell if you don't know the answer you
can chime in
this is totally cam it has to be
you're getting cam vibes from that oh
yeah i don't know why
the eyebrows probably the eyes i don't
know daddy
[ __ ]
i'm seeing a lot of seeing lots of cams
i have some advice i could help you with
every parent but i don't go ahead
i'd say face shape is the most useful
with every parent
okay
that tip was so useful you weren't sure
if to say it or not because i don't want
to kill the game because i thought they
want to make it too easy ends the game
it's so good it's such a good tip well
this gentleman has a very similar face
shape
i don't see cam's face shape in that
i see olivia's face shaping that
i see
that's it i see olivia what do you guys
think i see mine dude
zach they're all zach's dad
you think this is it could it be dan's
dan dad
dad when
what
[Laughter]
can be cam's dad
everybody's saying every get dad is cams
hmm
people are saying ian
you know i'm gonna be honest i've seen a
picture of ian's dad he looks just
[ __ ] like him
wait what this is the integrity of the
game i'm just being honest
why are you you showed me a picture of
him once oh
once i don't know if i remember
[ __ ] who is this whose dad is this you
guys are not helping me again dad like
god you guys are so unhelpful in the
chat
one hundred percent dan daddy so i'm i'm
torn between
dan and olivia
i ain't your daddy
let's put him in
let's put them in olivia's for now okay
because dan said the minute you see my
dad it'll be so obvious and i just don't
see it there it's not super obvious to
me
okay who's this
golly these are harder than i thought
it'd be
another beautiful young lady
curly hair
i've
i'm not gonna give any hints but i find
this one
to be as obvious as zack's dad that's
how like obvious this one is to me is
that olivia
or i don't see that everyone is my
parents it's not that obvious
the smile and the jawline
i agree with that exactly the same clone
yeah it's olivia's mom okay so do we
have a so so we got to take olivia's mom
back into the pile did i
my other mom
my brother mom sorry don't take her away
we're taking her out so this is olivia's
mom
interesting
if it is
it's not that obvious
right
that's okay what
i'd say
so you don't even think that's olivia's
mom
no
just to throw a little bit of a
curveball this is so hard
[Laughter]
that's ian's dad
nailed that dude dude his look is just
stellar it's so cool what a g bro he
looks famous
you had an earring dude
that guy's it's an english man right
there in there that is one of the most
british people i've ever seen in my life
in it
some veins and toes today you know i'm
sorry if this offends you but uh he
[ __ ] for sure i got plugs oh he for
sure the british punk are you kidding me
with that earring
everyone sees that this is ian right
dude you guys all got to stop they're
put you're still typing yeah it's ian
okay everyone
it's not your id ian's dad
that face shape is right on everything's
happening here
beautiful eyes your dad has beautiful
eyes
what color are your eyes ian
uh well i've i have brown eyes no you
got shafted on this this got this man
this man
that does have blue eyes
yeah i haven't seen him before this this
strange man
all right that's ian's dad i have blue
eyes
interesting
[Music]
that's ian's dad
all right nothing you guys can say to
get my head on that okay okay
who is this
oh my god
this is so hard
huh
oh
[Music]
abs mom is white it could be abs
mom right my mom is white yeah she's a
white lady
oh my god oh my i think this might be
abs mom
just throw me all the white women
where do my women at
what do you guys think
i'm seeing a b olivia guys we already
did olivia
because they're confusing the hell out
of me
i see a little bit of sam wait zach's
zach's mom i've met zach's mom but
i don't think that's her
is that crazy i met your parents
pretty wild
zach you guys heard this story a
thousand times but zack's dad was trying
to
be our realtor a few years ago when we
were buying the house
and your mom used to always come
she in fact did
it's funny
called him the todd and tuck
[Music]
i think this is abs mom
okay i've uh thrown her over there okay
justine
moving on oh who the [ __ ] are you
hold the phone
love that jacket
this guy [ __ ] this guy he's got very
red who in here gets
red
[ __ ]
could that be cam's dad
i'm seeing a little dan
dan yeah
this is so hard
wait is that your dad dan
i don't know i don't know people are
saying cam i'm actually seeing a cam
which
confused me because i already gave cam a
dad
he has two two dads maybe even has three
like ordering i was gonna say you're one
day away from the quartering
daddy
well he has three black dads three black
dads and one wife yeah he technically
has four dads
golly
well this gentleman has colored eyes
pam what color your eyes
[Music]
brown
so
strong jawline
okay high cheekbones
okay beautiful jacket
you're trying to get you could say who
you think it is
this is the one i had no clue i think
it's got you know what i'm putting him
in cam
we gotta take that slick that out
or whoever that guy's
and we gotta get cam's dad in there okay
interesting oh i see it dude he looks
just like him when you see him next to
each other
don't they they have like this i don't
know it looks like cam now
uh
do you guys see it
do you see it huh did you say it
people are some people are saying sam
i'm gonna leave that in cams dad
and we're gonna have to move on here a
little bit
cam and olivia are taking all of our
parents you're showing the audience the
close-up of the photo right ian yeah
okay oh [ __ ] that's aby's mom
take it back do you see it because i saw
you were showing a picture of her you
have the hot mom who's like
hot on the market that's your mom
yep
how's your mom by the way you doing good
lovely did any of your family see the
show on wednesday or throw monday uh
no but my mom's watching right now i
think
she is i think so yeah because i asked
her for the picture so oh excuse you
know she's gonna be talked about
hi abs mom
your mom
don't watch monday's episode okay
chat got
it got what nothing
bro stop
what that [ __ ] walking was that some
kind of joke
no no no they're just saying it's
clearly my mom oh
i'm trying to make it seem like i'm not
getting your jokes again
that's aby's mom though you could switch
out um i did yeah okay okay
okay interesting shout out amy's mom how
you doing
you can call in if you want if you're
watching
you can give her the link
a b she won't i doubt it she won't you
can try
i'd like to say hi to that mom
you should no it'd be funny you should
go toe-to-toe with her what uh what am i
pushing too hard it's funny no you push
as hard as you want
i guarantee you she's actually
background jesus
what was wrong zach
i think it was just so blunt
love to talk to that mom
just kidding around i think about dads
who the who is this
this one is obvious to me
really
i've probably been wrong every time i
said that this far though that is a very
powerful mustache
extremely powerful yeah
let's see there's
well dan is like a blank slate now
let's just say i i i might guess why dan
doesn't like mustaches
maybe
you think it's dan's dad
yeah he has beautiful blue eyes which
dan shares that characteristic
oh my god
people are saying sam yeah i mean i
don't know i
can't imagine what sam's dad looks like
sam has beautiful blue eyes too
and also similar eyebrows
hmm
torn between you know what i think it's
sam's dad
where's your daddy
i think we've found sam's dad
all right throwing it down
interesting
oh that's olivia's mom
right well you have somebody who's
olivia mom already
[ __ ] that's like your fifth mom yeah
that's olivia's mom who else is my
who you guys that's olivia right it's
gotta be
i don't know this back doesn't have a
mom i thought that was olivia's mom i
feel like i know what zack's mom looks
like you thought that was olivia's mom
when i first saw him i feel i see like
it's ex exact that has to be olivia's
mom it's like a the face shape is like
identical dude so we switch them out
this is your fifth mom of the day it is
maybe i'll like this one a lot we'll see
that's gotta be olivia's mom
okay moving on
oh okay interesting
stud
that zach's that's got to be i mean
that's got to be dan's dead
i feel it
it's got to be right let me see dan can
you look at the camera
dude it's dan he looks just like dan
he looks just like dan dude
that guy [ __ ] dude he had to get like
his face all obscured and [ __ ] too so i
wouldn't see it right away
that's gotta be dan's dad
yeah everyone's spamming dan
funny when
moving on
damn okay who's this who's this
[Music]
easy
easy tiger
just saying you guys have some beautiful
moms
it's a compliment
don't give me baby block to me batman
when did i get the beautiful world oh my
god
[Music]
come on baby
so beautiful
[Music]
whose mom is this
golly
whose mom is this
this is another one
to me this one is like
instant pick
sam sam i see sam's face
so wait is that sam's 20th mom too
that's sam that's sam it's gotta be
right guys
wait zach [ __ ] i forgot about zack's mom
too
[ __ ] man she's so [ __ ] sexy
wait zach wouldn't play that about his
own mom there's no shot
no shot a little meta gaming no [ __ ]
shot maybe i would because i'm just
[ __ ] nuts yeah you might have done
that no i'm going to say sam for now
let's say sam well so are we swapping
then
yeah for now i'm going to go over my
answers
zack if you played that for your own mom
we got to talk after the show
talk to me baby i have the great luxury
of coming
there's no shot you would play that for
your mom who the what what
whoa whoa
oh lee
who is he
oh my god i feel like i know him
wait where's what happened to abe's dad
too
i feel like i know this guy i've been
asking myself the same question for
years
[Laughter]
but isn't your
but this is like a totally white dude
your dad is daddy arabic right
yeah
i'm neon i might be racially profiling
but that is not that just looks like a
white ass dude no
it's got killer hair dude but but at the
same time
he does look like a b isn't that weird
straight hair too do you have straight
hair
yeah yeah yeah
big ass eyes
definitely
daddy
[ __ ]
does this guy look arabic to you uh ab
no no but neither do i that guy's name
you look arabic you think so that guy's
name is bradley a little bit enough
wait his name's bradley and he skates
i'm just oh yeah
that is not an arabic man exactly this
is bradley bro
this ain't no abraham or whatever brad
lives in venice dude he [ __ ] parties
that's what [ __ ] takes gnarly bong
ribs like this guy
that wallpaper is very arabic
it is how is that like gonna what i feel
like it's pretty standard oh no
we got flowers on everything
so are you trying to tell me this is
your dad cause you already made one joke
about it no it's not my dad
because my mom's white like we're like
this would be i'd be too white yeah
oh [ __ ] then whose dad is this
could well the olivia pop potentially
because i don't think that's olivia's
dad who'll be pegged there in fact you
can remove olivia's dad
so
we don't have lena's dad we don't have
i don't
um
[ __ ] so
cameron it's not dan it's not ian
i guess it could be sam's
love we have pegged
look this is basically the same photo
look at love's family photo above him
it just looks like the same photo
[ __ ]
all right put it on a b for now cuz i
just i have no other guess
somehow your dad's brad
how the [ __ ] is your dad brad bro
i don't know man
all right now i gotta go through this
one more times i'm super confused
okay so this lady is homeless right now
this has got to be zach's mom yeah this
is zack's mom which one are you looking
at
the top one the first one
this has got to be zach's mom oh there
it is
uh okay so we're going to say i see i
see zach here got it okay
moving down
this is love's dad right this is a or
lena's mom
lena is your dad also arabic
yeah he is okay
zach
this one's a stumper man let me see
it could be cam's mommy that one that
one's easy for me
you think that's cam's mom i didn't say
that you can guess unless you know
i think that's cameron's mom now that is
limiting the options here
okay over on camera okay
[Music]
oh you know who else it could be ian's
mom
don't have one for ian yet as well
that's true
wow is that ian or cam's mom well i have
it under s
people are saying sam's mom i i
personally see sam but i i don't know i
honestly don't know didn't i already
have her for sim or no i changed it out
yeah you swapped it was originally was
this is a tough one this is a wild card
this might be ian's mom
this might be ian's mom ladies and
gentlemen
okay
okay let's put her there
wow this one's tough
this one this man is a mystery to me oh
this guy's arabic for sure
i just figured it out
in a song
this guy's arabic for sure
and he's doing some kind of official
[ __ ] he's in a suit lina what's your dad
do for a living
construction
this is your dad abby
so his dad isn't brad is what you're
saying bro no no no get brad out of
there ah there's a nice bean that's your
dad first sure
but this guy this is this is the arabic
dad wild card i think
[Music]
also he's very light-skinned which i
think explains your
white passing-ness
or the white mother
we know her shout out
i want that whatever she's eating
damn okay
it's just salami bro talk to me
to the salami that's not the only thing
i want a slice of
[ __ ]
is saying lena's dead is bread
okay now who the [ __ ] is this this one
is really confusing
i this is by far
the easiest for me why do you like that
one easy i really do i feel like it's
easy okay let me look through here so
almost on the level of some of the other
ones it could be olivia it could be
he doesn't look arabic to me that looks
like a white dude see for me it's almost
like the level of my dad
yeah yeah what all of us feel like it
this one is like an instant pick what
yeah
i'm trying to see what if chat thinks so
too
it takes a minute for chat to catch up
which doesn't help for me
what do you guys think this is an easy
one wait everyone's saying cam
seriously
this guy or this guy
for cam
what
all right let's put him let's put him
right next wait everyone no you guys
there's not there's not a united front
in the chat on this
here what do you think
can we do a poll can i can i do a poll
ask the audience maybe i get one poll
right i need some like sure why not some
millionaire who is it between yeah so it
would be between cam
cam
or uh
sam
sam
nice music change
or
show zoom out let me see
we can
olivia
that needs a dad olivia needs a dad
yeah and olivia i guess
let's see what the voting is this is my
lifeline all right here's the lifeline
here we go
yeah these answers are everywhere i
don't know who's who's dead this is
bring up the picture again i think it's
a little bit confusing
yeah whose dad is this chat
okay we're taking it oh wow
cam's dad has a commanding lead
with 75 i guess in the eyes i do see it
this man is a honk cam
he looks kind of jacked
muscular
nice beard beautiful hair
[ __ ] there's something about the smile
of the other guy that's throwing me off
though that looks seems very cameron
but the people have spoke oh see now
it's getting haha
let's just do cam i mean apparently
everyone says it's obvious it's hard for
me bring that guy back out okay
but to to be fair that paul was a little
bit biased because
i i bet a lot of people would have voted
cam on the other one too
why
because
because you you only had like the vote
on that one i think both of them looks
like cam i think so too they both
got a lot of do you want to do it again
for this other gentleman i feel like we
should alright
against each other
like i already have fun i use my
lifeline
okay
okay zoom out
so this guy's a mystery now
and then this is uh
whose mom did we pick this for
or she's off she's off off the grid so
this is another one that everyone's like
oh this one's so obvious super obvious
was she a good mom too during that time
when she was yeah
miss her
this could be cam's mom it could be
it could be well dan has a mom i
wouldn't consider that possibility
when
[ __ ] i don't know who the [ __ ] this is
w damn yeah in fact it's just me and cam
that don't have moms and olivia
no olivia does
no it's just the two of us wait where's
olivia's dad no we're saying mom
oh
right
i'm gonna say i'm gonna say for now oh
[ __ ]
and who's the other lady
that lady let me let me see this lady
this lady or this lady
[Music]
[ __ ]
i'm gonna say this one's you dan
which one the nice lady in the blue coat
there okay having a toast
and i guess this means that
this lady's camera but i don't think
that's right
i'm just i'm who the [ __ ] is your dad
lina
i can't say
what
i how was one of these guys your dad
he said oh wait this guy's your dad bro
this is another arabic dude i just
spotted him
wait this is your dad for sure take him
out
this is your dad lena you come by that
arabic dude i just forgot you know
sometimes it's hard to spot like we be
hiding that dude's have arabic
so
now sam
all right i got you pegs lina
sam and olivia are the ones missing dads
so these two [ __ ] are all that remain so
who's who so whose dad is this one this
one is so well first of all brad
that's got to be olivia's dad daddy
because like who else's would it be
the only two options left so yeah it's
brad
that's wait so your last name is lopez
no it's lopes
i mean some people in my family say
lopez
we're white and hispanic on my desk okay
so
your dad is hispanic
christopher joaquin
[ __ ]
because that's that's crap that just
leaves this one for sam
oh my god is that the final thing that's
that's it that's the that's it
that's this bet i think that's as good
as i'm gonna do but i'll be honest
um you should show my parents too do we
have pictures
would you be able to guess i look a lot
like my my mom but i don't see anything
in my dad oh yeah where do you think you
get that amazing hairline
so true
actually i have my grandpa mom's dad
oh really
yeah well you're dead you know he's up
there in age and he has full head no he
has good hair he does have good hair but
you mean like the widow's peak is your
mom's side dude i have the same hair my
grandpa he died when he was like 92
[ __ ] full dark head of hair
same curly ass [ __ ] not died
no
okay no insane i know well i got my
dad's grays but i got okay but okay
let's take let's take a look so i think
how we should do this is we'll go from
left to right
and people will verify
if you got it right if you didn't on one
or the other i'll then remove them from
the pool and then i'll at the very end
i'll reveal all the correct answers so
olivia
those are my parents
yes
so your dad's hispanic is fair he's
white and hispanic so he's half half
yeah italian is he a skateboarder cool
ass [ __ ] he's a hockey player oh
[Music]
his name's chris which is close to brad
in a way
yeah he's always been a joke i would
have laughed if he said brad because i
didn't actually know his name i just
kind of like picked what i thought and
your mom your mom looks uh very similar
what's her story
her name is brenda she's a queen she's
from maine long island queen bernie baby
she jewish
oh just everyone's there is jewish in
long island
uh so then all right well there you have
it olivia
god can't this one is so hard for me i
see it in the eyes to be honest now that
i'm looking at cam's dad the eyes
but cameron go ahead and tell us how did
we do
that is not my mom
okay but it is your dad that is my dad
but the fact the fact that you struggled
so much with that and like chat was like
very high on there like are you face
blind or something dude like it looks so
much his eyes his his beard his head
i mean it's like
it's cam i see
i don't know damn squint your eyes
right
oh there he is
well i got the right answer so what did
you do you did get the right yeah you
got it yeah but it took a bit to get
there and and the fact that uh i don't
even say
i'll get back to it yeah we'll get back
to it all right your dad by the way
your dad is a hunk man he's super he's a
jack yep i miss you dad you were a
bodybuilder and oh he was a bodybuilder
for a little bit yeah there you go rest
in peace dad all right peter the goat
yeah it's all good the goat hmm
all right lena i feel confident lina
what what did i get here yes those are
my arabic looking yeah killed it
[ __ ] spotted your dad i knew lina's
day would be a wild card with blonde
hair and blue eyes
but once you yeah
that's in yeah yep yep yep but he does
also look very arab so yeah he's got the
vibe he does have the vibe
uh a b
dude that's gotta be your daddy b tell
me i'm wrong that's my father yeah
nailed
it that's your dad
your dad is an interesting guy huh
yep that's him training to be a lawyer
right yep
working at the gas station at night and
then going to law school during the day
at that time that's why it looks like
that's a hustle man yeah they had me
young too bad he's got a new family now
yeah they get to enjoy the good [ __ ]
i get to i saw that look for 20 years
oh [ __ ]
i like his build though he looks
interesting he got like a big face
not in a bad way
not a bad way he's got a prominent face
my dad's jacked he's jacked yeah he was
a boxer when he was younger is he
handsome yes yeah yeah beautiful man
zach that's got to be your [ __ ] that's
got to be your parent that is not my
father
stop
is that your mom that that is that is my
beautiful mother stacey yeah okay okay
nailed it you played those sound bites
about her oh no no no that was a
different one yeah different one got it
i was right on that by the way you zack
i don't know i see your them
your face is like so much like both of
theirs i know i have my my mom's nose
um i can really tell that and like
you've got cheeks you've got you share
her cheeks yeah but then i get my my
dad's red face and like it is it is like
a perfect mix yeah
okay so far so good not bad huh not bad
no i've only got one wrong
i wonder if i would yep got my dad right
you know i wonder
i don't think he would have got it right
this one is a big question mark for me
confidence is low but dan
uh that is my father that is not my
mother oh
[ __ ] okay all right
okay at least i got one right you got
one right
uh
ian
i know that's ian's dad no question i've
never seen that bruv in my life right
no that's my dad that's my dad that is
not my mom
[ __ ] okay
yeah those ones were hard damn okay
interesting
and then
samantha sam what what's going on here
those are my parents oh my god
whoa
you know how i caught on is when we put
them next to each other because it looks
like the same photo shoot
is that is they from the same photo i
think it is they were on their honeymoon
trip and so i think they were just super
tan
yo
that's true
the tux is incredible
wait was that the one we were doing the
sound bites
yes yes it is zach come on have some
respect you guys think it's a joke all
right
have some respect all right and then
love did we get those
of course yeah yeah the two most nordic
looking people in this whole lineup are
of course
love your parents though is that you
thank you
is that you as a baby love yes sir are
you an only child
yep i am
yeah i get told that i look a lot like
my parents so yeah that makes sense that
you got that definitely see it
so we have three were you did your
parents always tell you that your mom
was hot love or is that an american
thing
no my no not really and my parents has
been divorced since i was like two years
old so i
i've never really heard my parents talk
in that way about each other
yeah and and you live with your dad
right
well growing up i lived the half half so
just back and forth but when i started
working i needed like a big pc uh
and i couldn't like bring it back and
forth obviously so so you know i just
live with my dad i see i see your does
your mom and dad live in the same town
yeah we both
in the same city um they've always been
very
very friendly with each other nothing
weird like that yeah it's very nice is
your mom single or no
yeah both my parents are yeah man
any chance of getting them back together
parent trap i don't think so because if
they're both single they have a kid they
have so much in common a slice segment
can we get a parent trap going all right
all right so i've i've put
the wrong moms above where you had them
so you need to shuffle these three
around all right i gotta get this right
yeah so
let's focus on cam's mom here
can you bring them together and zoom in
so i can put them all above cameron so i
can yeah
yeah give me a zoom there
okay
cameron we got your dad
we got your dad
how do you not see this
just just look at that picture of cam
yeah and then look
i mean i don't remember which one i
chose for him originally it was the
blonde lady on the left here
okay because that's the one i still see
right so i mean i could just remove that
because we know that one's wrong so it's
between these you
[ __ ]
i'm gonna say the curly haired lady
okay which would make this
your mom
wow is that your mom that's so
interesting and then that lady's ian's
mom that makes sense to me oh i forgot
ian
but yeah
okay so how do we do here in the
reshuffle
that is the correct line wow that's
everybody for all of them that's
everybody's correct wow wow
you know i think we did pretty well what
this is gender swap cam like how do you
know like look at that i feel like
that's one of the easiest ones
look at that smile ready yeah yeah oh
they're all the easiest no but look at
this
that's the same person
look at cameron's beautiful punim
wait let me see there's my phone your
mom interesting very straight hair
beautiful mom by the way thank you thank
you and your parents are happily
together right they are okay
so you're saying there's no chance
there no chance for you yeah no no it's
okay not happening
well i'm happily married too yeah right
of course
and then this one makes sense to me now
that i see it
the lovely couple
but
but i boy do i see your dad's i don't
know why
yeah i don't know why
but there you have it folks that was
pretty fun oh that was fun
you can't seem pretty into it meet
everybody's parents
he said
dan your mom and cams have the same
smile in my opinion i mean
i could see it a little bit
did my internet just go out
you think they're sisters
no it could be yeah mom's got a big
family so
well that was fun thanks for playing
who's the parent game
brought to you by 23andme just kidding
i wish but 23m reach out
thanks for playing
now we're going to play who's the
hottest no i'm just kidding
that'd be horrible
um
and were you guys did you guys have any
trouble with your parents getting these
photos were they all pretty happy to
participate
my parents were happy to participate
they're frequent watchers so they'll
probably oh yeah i love your parents my
dad mostly my dad your dad my mom
occasionally dude i love your dad what's
that name
larry larry shout out larry my boy we're
dogs
i would dab up your dad if i ever met
him
i've always said that once every oh
sorry not not on the same level as
uh jimmy and your dad but your dad and
my dad would be fast friends that's
interesting and but will your dad be
larry and gary
hold on would your dad be friends with
jimmy then by transitive property
no i don't think my dad would care for
jimmy
uh well my dad loves dan
well your dad your dad loves me yeah
well your dad looks like he [ __ ]
i'll make sure he knows he looks like a
brad who [ __ ] serves dude
wait what how's your dad feel about me
loves okay good okay good but he's
always like damn he was on it
your dad watches
yeah sometimes shout out man shout out
brad or alex brad
chris chris how did uh
baby pics next maybe we can do that next
week we can only bring baby
so you're all your parents were willing
participants yeah interesting well i
texted my dad for a photo and he didn't
reply i still haven't heard back from
him but he's in lebanon so i'm guessing
it's something to do with the service uh
where how did you get it from your mom
no i just had photos but i wanted to see
if there's one that he preferred oh okay
interesting
my mom had a very mom moment first
because i i explained all of like what
we were doing and she was down and then
she sent me a photo which was a nice
photo but it was like a photo from when
she was in a play or something and it's
like from
halfway back in the audience and she's
like really tiny and i'm like this
doesn't really help for like what we're
trying to accomplish by the way your dad
photo was very hard to spot just because
it was like so dark lots of hair i
remembered this photo and i specifically
asked my dad to send this one because
most photos of my dad it would be like
like zach's basically it would be and
you still got it pretty much instantly
so there you go
next we can guess each other's social
security number
that sounds great
my mom just texted me and said tell zach
he's my fave let's go
let's go
zachary thank you denise
[Laughter]
oh
god i'll tell you what we learned a lot
we come we came a long way how long
we've been going we've been going for
just a hair under three hours yeah
because do you guys want to do my uh the
one dedicated to my biggest hater
the one
i mean i vote yes i gotta
i've been dying during this whole
segment so i sent my mom in the zoom
link
a while ago she here she just she's not
in the lobby
but that'll be interesting if you were
to uh join in i was kind of curious how
that would go kind of interested
[Laughter]
would she go in on anything possibly my
mom's really good on her toes so okay
i'm curious i think she might talk about
your dad
everything lisa my dad yeah
he said dan's mom was so obvious because
of what he said about her working on
sesame street and that pic was very
professional looking big head shot vibes
that is correct that was a head shot
from when she was an actress oh nice oh
that's weird very good
logic on their part yeah i didn't even
think about that
yes indeed was she ever in a movie with
bruce willis that you know of no okay
because i thought she she looked a lot
like the girl from pulp fiction to me
uh bruce willis girlfriend in that movie
oh it's not a chocolate
haircut yeah yeah no that is not it's
not your mom i would have mentioned if
my mom was in a clinton-terran team i
don't know man you'd be humble so
[Laughter]
i was pretty stoked to look like av is
dead yeah dude
he's a legend you have a middle eastern
dad dude hell yeah dude
i'm gonna get a photo
uh from my dad
i called i called i kept calling you
wouldn't answer and i called my brother
and he's like oh he's in the woods
he's in how long has he been in the
woods he's been like three days
he that he just got like that's his new
thing he just goes into the woods
wilderness man huh yeah he's just
camping
yeah he goes like
in desolation wilderness like by himself
for like a week
that's the dream right it's awesome your
dad's like jack ian right
yeah i don't know what happened like
this guy's out in the woods jack
doing god knows what
there's this guy this
i feel that i was i was trying to look
for a picture of my dad that doesn't
look like me but that's just impossible
that does not exist yeah you guys are
like clones i know django boba fett
thing i know it's weird so is this the
photo that looked the least amount like
you
i guess oh my god
i saw it and i was like why did zack
give a photo of himself
but yeah his hair his hair rolled back
in the middle
yeah
sure
should we yeah we should give him a
heads up
oh his mom and the maybe the waiting
maybe
hey ethan
there's somebody on the line who wants
to speak to you
you're
yo you're in trouble you're in trouble
[Music]
that's my mom abey's mom is here
[Music]
yes
you ready
you asked for it
oh my god
i didn't expect this
i mean you
bring her on bring her on all right here
we
go stand by gotta make sure i look good
stop
all right let's just give it a second
what's what's her name rhonda ronda is
giggling in the back
i feel like i'm prank calling your mom
no i don't know if this is
uh
just waiting on the uh
love your dad watches every episode
that's so cool
yeah
uh he i think he skims through until he
sees me
rhonda
uh
still can't hear audio isn't connected
yet rhonda yeah
there's someone in the car next to her
still
better not be oh do you know who is that
it's her boyfriend
who is it it's her friend
it's your friend her boyfriend her
boyfriend mom how you going to
disrespect me you see it's not the jokes
i can't understand what he says i don't
know why the jewish guy right abe [ __ ]
you zack what's wrong with that
uh
this is a real mom uh yeah this is donna
vibes right yeah
hey
all right amy's mom
calling into the show how about this huh
how are you
good how are you very good
hi mom
hi
what's going on i heard you are very
beautiful and you are so it's nice to
see you uh abc said lots of nice things
about you
okay awesome he says nice things about
you too
okay good good so we're on the same page
there
so um gee whiz where do we go with this
one
how are you so i i mean uh do you you
probably miss a b right you move to l.a
you don't see him as much yeah
yeah we most definitely miss him he
asked
you know you guys talk how often do you
guys talk on the phone
uh every so often like once a week does
he call you enough rhonda
no he doesn't yeah
how often does he call you
he calls me more now that he's in
california than he did when he was here
so
like once like once a week or less than
that
no once or twice a week once or twice a
week and and you would prefer to talk to
him every day probably huh
yeah yeah is there can we make that
happen maybe i mean she is your mom oh
for any anything yeah of course whatever
you want mom
cool
okay
and um can i say hi to your uh
a lovely jewish boyfriend
hi
what's your name i'm also i'm also
jewish nice to meet you
nice to meet you too hi steve
steve hi eb how are you good how are you
no
no abe put forth a theory
that
that uh
sorry what's your mom's name again
rhonda rhonda
may be dating a jewish man as a despite
her ex-husband do you think that has any
uh credence not to say that she doesn't
like you for who you are but maybe
that's a subconscious factor
it certainly is a uh
a not very common dynamic right there it
is destroying my life so yes in other
words
well nice to meet you no i do not
believe that's behind her motivation
okay okay sure yeah absolutely just abe
said that those are abe's words not mine
steve's a good guy me and my siblings
all give the thumbs up
steve what do you do for a living
i'm in the commercial real estate
business right wow okay let's go steve
nice
excellent okay fantastic
uh do you talk to steve when you call
her just your mom
just my mom's just here i say tell him
hi
mm-hmm yeah tell him hi how's he doing
first time we've talked on the phone
yeah i know it's weird
uh steve your stepson is uh or not snap
son you guys aren't married excuse me av
not yet a b is uh you're
let's say honorary st how do i refer to
you guys relationship
well we're friends
he's a celebrity how do you how do you
guys feel about ab being a celebrity i
mean that's really a question more for
for your mom isn't it
well steve keeps up actually you do see
i've watched a little bit yeah i've been
entertained and but i've been very
impressed with uh
a b story how he ended up there and
period time he's been there it's uh
it's uh beyond impressive right it's
inspiring isn't it thank you steve
you're welcome amy
yeah okay interesting so are you guys
living together or not yet
we live about five minutes apart
so no
not yet no so how long you guys been
dating
about a year and a half a year and a
half i mean it i i i mean your guys's
age is probably time to move in don't
you think
[Laughter]
i mean i was a lot younger than me i
mean let's get let's get moving steve
um if
you give me your number i call you for
some you know inside advice maybe
okay i can we can do that i can set that
up for you
okay well
what are you all trying to accomplish
here today with that's a good question i
don't really know uh
just trying to embarrass av i think
ethan want to see how hot my mom was and
then he got sam cedared when you were in
the yeah
we're just saying no that's the one
question i would have of the show
because every time i watched it i said
to myself what are they trying to
accomplish today yeah
it's kind of just me that's true he
asked me all the time so what are you
guys
what are you going to do
we don't know
we're still figuring it out yeah
well nice uh uh nice chatting with you
steve um pleasure yeah absolute pleasure
keep it up
are you bar mitzvah steve
i am bar mitzvah yes me too
what was your torah portion do you
remember
no that was uh
what 51 years ago so now wow let me do
the math on that
that was before you were born [ __ ]
[Laughter]
let me crunch the numbers on that all
right thank you steve let me
let me just say goodbye to uh rhonda
so rhonda nice meeting you thanks for
calling in
thank you thanks for having us and a b i
mean call your mom more i mean that's
kind of what we yeah i agree yeah
i mean it's the least
it's the least he can do after
everything you've done for him
right exactly
bye mom
bye bye steve hi guys thanks for calling
bye nice talking to you guys nice
chatting you guys are a wonderful couple
and uh let's get the ball rolling okay
there's not much time thank you bye mom
bye thank you guys
yeah i am
that was so interesting
that was so interesting the things i do
to try and be entertaining on the show
wow well she called in she was a
reluctant colin did you have to like
talk her into that or no i just entered
the link i said if you want to call in
well it might be funny she did not
mention steve steve's a great guy i love
meeting steve yeah yeah
you're a fan
well we have a lot in common maybe an
after dark my dad and his girlfriend
maybe the kids that would be awesome i
wouldn't say no to that
i'd love to chat with your dad and his
girlfriend
uh this is weird man much respect to you
couldn't have paid me to do that
honestly
[Laughter]
oh yeah 40 days i've been watching more
howard stern and i'm thinking like to
just be as open as possible because i
always find that most entertaining but
that's my policy yeah but i can't i
can't put that policy on you guys but i
appreciate it i mean that was a great
call nothing to be embarrassed about
lovely
you know
steve's a legend though man
yeah i
love him
great guy no in all seriousness he
really does like keep up and no one else
in my family like
they barely even know your guys names
wow okay well that was
thank you this amy's family uh up next
week his his dad and girlfriend so
all right let's move on to my biggest
hater
this is something so i've been you know
sometimes i wonder you guys probably
wonder too like
who are these people
that obsess over
trying to like expose me or something
like
with the teddy fresh plagiarism thing
who's like people are curating this and
constantly busting it everywhere
and we i think um ab brought something
interesting to my attention
some [ __ ] fantastic clips
i'm a huge and they're so funny it's a
it's a conflict for me because you know
obviously i love you and i'm a sim
for the show but i do love this person i
i can't deny it well his name is
beaublox boby
boby there's bobby
and he like he's it's just so funny i
mean i got these clips of him having
like a full-on
uh [ __ ] fit over me
it's just so funny look how much he
cares about it
this was on twitter i clicked on beau
black's stream and this literally
happened so here let's see
let's watch
these are my haters
shout out just to give some context
right before this clip love says keem's
audio is off or delayed
right we were watching keem
get all angry about the teddy fresh [ __ ]
and uh we were criticizing um yeah
remember he was
wearing the headphones and stuff and his
audio was all out of sync and
he had a microphone but it wasn't being
used recording on his phone it just
really bothered me it was horrible
honestly horrible yeah terrible audio
production quality yeah [ __ ] okay okay
and um by the way
by the way his whole [ __ ] recommended
bar is [ __ ] people making [ __ ] [ __ ]
videos about it
all of ethan klein
is guilty i mean bro do you just want
like do you have
any other heart job
hold on
dude just give him a chance
two of the six videos showing here are
videos [ __ ] on me
but okay 929 viewers that's pretty
significant let's watch audio is
slightly delayed
talk about the allegations
talk about these this
this this is why i'm watching i don't
give a [ __ ] about keemstar's audio
levels the audio numbers right now on my
screen are probably way too [ __ ] loud
yo that was literally the joker
spazz
[Laughter]
these are my haters
oh my god
i [ __ ] love that [ __ ] just the sound
bite potential in that is yeah it's
beautiful it's a symphony
so angry what did i [ __ ] do oh the
alligator you didn't talk about it i'm
talking about
the allegations
you know what's wrong with the batman
every time he's accused of something he
doesn't address it
then like the noises he made at the end
it's almost like eric the actor material
man like it's just it's perfect
i gotta watch this one more time there's
actually more like this though
people are saying dude is 15 he's
actually 25 yeah no he's not i wanted to
make sure he wasn't a child before i did
this
nice try nice try he's [ __ ] 25. yeah
try to kill her fun another another way
not happening
leo is slightly delayed
talk about the allegations
i am such a big fan
also he's wearing a shirt that says
[ __ ] station yes indeed
excuse me using that vulgar word i think
that's his merch oh he sells that i'm
i'm not making a joke i really think it
is i think that's ricky berwick's oh
ricky's okay i need somebody's merch
is that a that's a play on playstation
yeah those words don't even sound
similar though so it's not that clever
is it no it should be a play on words
it's boby logic man it just is
bobby well talking about stolen shirt
designs too like you know let's play all
right
you're right that's a good point talk
about these this this this is why i'm
watching i don't give a [ __ ] about
keemstar's audio levels the audio levels
right now on my screen are probably way
too [ __ ] loud because i [ __ ] [ __ ]
back
too
the levels were decent actually yeah i
was actually fine yeah yeah you're good
bobby yeah no worries
your audio is good so that's just one
and there's if you could believe it
there's more oh ela just donated 10
bucks
wow i'm dead
[Laughter]
yo ela that's our biggest hater yeah
about the allegations
that's our biggest hater right there you
listen
totally
totally hinged
he's on that hinge maybe you've met bobi
yeah yeah we we had a meeting wait
baby's dogs with boby what the [ __ ] my
boy man
wait hold on hold on
oh there's two photos i saw two photos
there's two yeah
here i'll throw up the other i don't
know why
yeah so oh you guys are pounding it yeah
yeah
they're dogs man after the crater clash
showing some love he went to the fight
no he he was supporting me like all
jokes aside he was sitting with a bunch
of people that hate me and he's
screaming my name go starkiller during
the fight legend loves you hates me huh
loves you hates me
like everyone who watches this show
so it sounds like you had an a pleasant
uh steve was an exchange with him yeah
he was nice
and then up next there's more
uh screams there's another one
of him
in an hour what is the context here okay
you guys are the you you're the well
it's important to not get hung up on the
context it's more about what he said
but
basically his friends are mad at him for
something he did
and uh they're kind of grilling him and
they don't let him talk so he gets upset
at this point
okay interesting well here we go it was
deleted by the way so this is coming
hard
we're in 45 minutes no that's not an
apology there's no apology that's
[Music]
just to let me speak
me and zach probably every day tell each
other let me speak like we
you showed me this what a year ago yeah
yeah and it would have been so perfect
we've always said
like just when people are talking over
each other just perfect well now you
have the sound access to the sound yeah
zach is like too powerful now we were
telling him
i feel like a large part of doing this
is just so that zach can have access to
that's really the motivator
let me speak
is this guy friends with keemstar is he
part of that whole thing well it's weird
because he is part of that crew but he's
beef with beau blacks a lot kim and
boblax and uh he's blocked
a few times but somehow they're in each
other's orbit yeah definitely yeah
they're part of the same multiverse for
sure
yeah
the league of extraordinary villains or
whatever it's crazy bro these guys i'm
batman in their life yeah i don't you
know i'm not trying to flatter myself i
mean the guy
they're oh interesting i am
and i'm not saying anything about you
know that i'm
you know i strike fear and justice and
all that just saying the way they're
obsessed
to give another pop culture reference i
think bobi is like vader like he's done
some bad [ __ ] but they're still good in
him we could still maybe bring him back
to the left we can bring bobby to the
light side
darth boby yeah
skywalker
darth mobius the darth vomit
darth bubbus the lost
dark bobas
boba fett so here's another one
how do you even find it okay so yeah let
me use context on this one just a little
bit because i don't even know the full
but just from watching it so many times
this person was scared that their
channel was going to get deleted and
when beau black's heard that he said
wait how many subscribers do you have
why are you so afraid your channel's
going to be deleted and so now he's
going to go search for how many subs
this person has and how do you find this
stuff because these seem to be buried
baby knows all the lore maybe maybe he's
the lore master of the screw i've muted
all the haters except him he's the only
one survived in all honesty all jokes
aside i had a really bad dream about my
grandma woke up really depressed i went
on the couch and i saw this video and i
swear to god it just it changed my whole
[ __ ] day
it changed yeah that's inspiring and
then he has those abilities he brought
in the office and coincidentally i was
having a rough day too and it just it
just lightened the mood yeah like it was
amazing he's like jesus
do you think he would be down to join
the crew
oh that'd be a dream ethan
i don't know what well here let's watch
so so here he's apparently uh let's see
are they talking live or is he just
watching the video
uh he's
watching live okay
bet you have nothing where's your
[ __ ] channel diva diva
diva phoenix diva man
steve i dude build up is so good where's
her channel man
where's her channel where's her channel
oh you're gonna go to her twitter who
are these goons talking behind them too
they're just like
[Laughter]
like a whole group of apes just like
all with joker paint on oh boy
oh what do you have
500 subs
500 subs you have to protect no one
gives a [ __ ] about you bro holy [ __ ]
holy [ __ ] you're saying on kiwi farm
slam supports what he did with xander
hall i can show screenshots from this
month
so why is he even dunking on these like
literally like these tiny no names can
it tell you i'm not that deep in i mean
we're short of doing that well i mean
he's a big deal he's got a lot of subs i
think he's like 300k or something yeah
roblox is a big deal he's yeah he yeah
he's got he's got a following
man
[Laughter]
he um
he had a thousand people watching his
live stream that's pretty impressive
he's got some he's got some cloud he's
clouded up
and we just cannot stop
saying this [ __ ] yeah he's infinitely
quotable is the problem
just can't stay away here's one about me
twitter versus ethan klein's nra bomb
scandal oh wow
that's ancient
talk history the allegations all right i
will
call lee
oh man bet you have nothing
you know what i i feel bad for a way
because i feel like
i don't want to make too many
assumptions but
i feel that this is what happens when
you get bullied so
and he kind of is trying to reclaim his
power he gives me yeah the dude wants
friends yeah and that's like maybe like
i said he can
we're all going to come back to the
light yeah
we can save you we can save you bobby
come back to the light come hither this
is what it looks like being friends with
keemstar by the way yeah
this is what friendship with keemstar
does to your brain digital
[ __ ]
that was so wild about okay there it is
our biggest shout out to our biggest
hater beau black
standing over boby
yeah when we're looking for a tweet and
we can't find it that's what we say we
say boby like he's the he's archives
everything that's good that's a service
um
[Applause]
oh there's another one there's so much
to talk about we still never get to the
trailer [ __ ]
i have like this huge breaking triller
scoop
i guess i'll save that for friday but
like i want definitely want to give a
shout out to bradley martin who we've uh
definitely
all right that was the squash the beef
and then yeah yeah so we got to squash
this wait we squashed uh
we squashed the difference
in beef yeah we did squash so there you
go
beef was squashed but this is the one
that we were talking about before that
curveball came out
uh bradley martin he's like this
swallowed guy he's got it
he owns a gym he hangs with the knick
boys
and during kovitt he um
he refused to close his gym and keep it
open
and then what was also crazy he had like
an insane fan meet up remember that
during covet where like hordes of people
were going there yeah
i vaguely remember that
but i mean you know
it's not again it's not like
these are unforgivable crimes you know
what i mean i want to talk about how
come i wasn't invited seven minutes [ __ ]
this is the edit too i want to squash
the beef probably i don't know if i got
that much time
uh ian you cut this together is there
any way to
expedite this
let's just watch
we'll just watch a bit and see all right
i want to talk about how come i wasn't
invited to the h3 podcast because i got
some [ __ ] that say to that [ __ ]
i was an h3 fan before i got into it uh
with him
and then afterwards he had stuck up for
me and even though he had my boy he
still you know stuck up for me so that
meant a lot to me and i wanted to
mend that relationship squash that i
love you jeffy good when i left there i
felt i felt real good it's good it was i
mean dude it worked out great for me
mike crushed it his alpha brain kicked
in he was on he was there he was talking
politics with him and he does a
political show too
they were really into that and their
audience was really into that yo this
guy's got monster thighs look at the
size of those things bro
you might enjoy me saying you are jacked
brother
you're [ __ ] yacked out of your mind
dude your thigh is as thick as my
goddamn
that's this becker look
yeah without even trying
my man
thai god
but yeah great crew over there great
audience he's got a great dude honestly
it sucked because he you know like
i had friends who had
real consequences because of
and maybe i take cross with this just
for the record maybe rightfully so i
don't [ __ ] know dude like i even had
real consequences for stuff that
you know wasn't true there was there was
like th you know he had
perp or perpetuated the story that i
would that i had done this crypto scam
when in reality it was just complete
[ __ ] and i'd never made a single
[ __ ] dollar off of it bro don't put
dink doink on me
i feel like he's backpedaling a little
bit on our amnesty
he can't be put he i'm saying you can't
blame me
for dink doing are we sure he's talking
about dingtoy because there was the
other crypto thing which one is that
where he like used his nft as a
collateral for alone well he said
i think he's talking about dick because
he said he lost sponsors because of the
dink donk video oh that what you're
right
he's like this video cost me oh you're
right you're right you're right
don't put that on me mikey
okay
he got he got tricked into doing that
dink donk video yeah it seems like it's
the fault of whomever trick i never yeah
i never asked for a dink donk video
okay
and i know nobody i mean listen you talk
just talked about it now i don't think
you guys ever even talked about ding
dong so
what do you want
come on mikey don't throw don't start
throwing me under the bus now we made a
lot of progress
and i lost the financial sponsor as a
result of the video that he made and so
i lost you know like 30 40 000 from a
from a financial sponsor and so like
there was real palpable reasoning for us
to have this dislike for each other and
also for other creators but
you know we got on the show we sat down
and talked to him he's a likable guy he
[ __ ] he had to be done yeah it had to
be done they're good at what they do i
love jeff
jeff is such a bro
such a bastard he's done obviously a
different style of content than we make
right but um yeah they're killing it and
thank you brother i don't want to have
beef south i don't mean i don't mind
i'll have beefs for life i'll take it to
the grave with certain people but
you know that's not one that i wanted to
have and a lot of it was just a
misunderstanding so we needed to just
get in there and chat and yeah it felt
good yeah how would you approach it
would you go in there just trying to
body slam everybody and i'm scared of
him bro he would crush my skull with one
[Laughter]
hand would squash the beef in your brain
that's right right
that's one way to squash the beef
place or body slam everybody
no honestly what is your issue with he
just had he i kept my gym open during
covet and he just ridiculed okay for it
basically and related like
my biggest issue the thing i just would
love to talk to him about is he tried to
relate like the gym and the importance
of the gym and i was speaking to like a
mental health standpoint as like it's
basically like laser tag and i'll just
never forget that i don't remember
exactly what we said but well his whole
argument and he wasn't the only one
making this argument but when the whole
debate about the lockdowns was happening
they closed a lot of gyms and a lot of
people were saying
that for a significant portion of people
that are that are gym rats the gym is
like their therapy and by closing that
you know essentially his argument was
that it is an essential service so i
think the point that we were making was
that
you know
a lot of people have passionate hobbies
and everybody was having a sacrifice and
you don't have to go to the gym to
exercise you can do it in your own home
you can run
there's a million ways that you can do
that
you know right and that's a good account
to keep healthy the gym isn't the only
place that you can do exercise i mean
there's a strong yeah legit the gym is
like you know
i see i say laser tag because it's silly
but it's like someone that might be
their passion in the way that they get
their [ __ ] out and feel better about
stuff but we were all asked to sacrifice
in that time
and
uh you refused
but that being said you know in
retrospect it's just not a big deal we
all got [ __ ] over by covet nothing we
never got to
we i mean there might be a little
argument that uh people like you my and
something to do with that man at this
point but uh by going to be bygones
i mean my fellow family just got covered
wait oh right couple with me right
you're a week correct yeah i thought you
were saying like your parents got there
or something no no no
so i don't know i personally don't
consider the gym an essential service
for those reasons but
but i i i don't again i don't think it's
like an unforgivable crime like you know
i think it's fine you know you made that
choice i criticized you for it you know
if you want to play laser tag i'm down
we can we can decide this over a laser
tag
that moment where he said that in a
video and he related the gym being like
well i really like laser tags so like i
should be able to laser tag it's the
same thing this guy's complaining about
and i just think obviously from him he
doesn't understand how actually
important it is for someone's mental
health like it was for me yeah
exercising is important for mental
health
you can do it
you don't have to do it in a tiny room
where everyone's sweating and breathing
and sharing space
during a pandemic you know it's all
ancient history now right it feels like
but i'm just saying at the time it was
felt pretty serious
so i just remember hearing that i mean
like this guy is a piece of [ __ ]
that's that's where i could that's
interesting well i agree with that a lot
of people hold that opinion about me and
i'm a hater ass [ __ ] so what can i do
i mean i'm coming out of the closet
that's a good argument see i like that
better than the body slamming technique
i'm going to reach out i'm going to try
to say i just asked him about i don't
have to buddy he'll he'll see it trust
me he has an army bigger
more
ferocious than any army on the internet
that will take
come on we love our family i mean he's
right though
we saw it because family saw this clip
posted on that
family family family family stop stop
we are legion hear us
or whatever
uh [ __ ] anonymous says anonymous
now we're good people right i mean we
don't
we're good people we're trying to be
yeah i think so
we are yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah
take that clip and it will get to them
and by the way it's a good it's a it's a
discussionary point and i i said to
ethan very specifically on that show a
lesson that my friend logan paul taught
me it is very dangerous to speak in
extreme absolutes in life and then and
to say to someone what you are doing is
100
uh unequivocally wrong
it's just i don't really get this point
i mean there's clearly things that you
can do that are unquestionably wrong or
right like
murder
right sexual assault but i get i mean
yes most things are more nuanced than
that right really hard to do that
because you can you could never predict
the angle for which someone does
something you don't know what they're
going through like yo
what if every person in that gym
without
workout was a detriment to it would be a
detriment to their mental health to not
be there and i think that's what you're
you're saying exactly what i was saying
but i i just i don't know why they're
making this special carve out for the
gym people have hobbies lots of hobbies
people were getting depressed and [ __ ]
up because they couldn't go see their
family they couldn't go to school they
couldn't go outside they couldn't do
this that it's all it was [ __ ]
everybody up you're not special because
you've lift weights bro
you know
you're jacked
you have massive [ __ ] thighs i like
to get squeezed between those you know
what i'm saying
but it doesn't make you special
right
thank you
and and so you know like i think
although it's a [ __ ] pandemic
oh boy
i'm just saying we're trying we're
trying we're trying
it's just not that crazy to criticize
that
it's not but it's a pig dammit
i'm sorry i was channeling blow black
talk about the allocation
bet you have nothing
my god i can't believe those sound bites
are so good
dream come true all right let me keep
logging 500 subs
i know i know i know
his eyes he may have been right that uh
a pandemic that was
at
it also was a different time bradley of
covid it was a different time i think
even near the end of covid we all were
just like dude this is [ __ ] this is
like dude being in la with this
[ __ ] the whole rest of the world
has has moved out of this phase and
we're still wearing our masks outside
like yes i think everybody fell off at a
different point but i think for you the
problematic situation was that it was
very early that's true thank you mike
okay mike's back on bestie
definitely we're vastly yeah i'll be
mike mike i'm team
[Applause]
that was a time when a lot of people
were very scared
and so i'm not saying either side was
right and you guys can hash that out and
have that conversation i simply do this
on podcasts where i present the opposing
viewpoint when they're not in the room
and so what i would what i would assume
was that ethan
was on that phase
you relate
they say that because i'm the devil
advocate guy yeah
he's trying to play that role
i don't even think this but just to play
devil's advocate for his
i don't think this just to play devil's
advocate but hitler was right
grabbed that sounds like that backed in
fear of the virus at that time and so he
was looking at it as an irresponsible uh
a tactic to do that thank you mike once
again you guys talking yeah i mean yeah
yeah well said thank you mike for saying
that appreciate you come over here your
best friend give me a hug
but like i'm just trying to get i think
it's more so related to probably the
other things that i was involved in at
the time which would have been like
making content with the milk boys and he
was he was kind of active on you know
not us doing other [ __ ] [ __ ] that he was
probably relating to this whole
situation let me ask you a question go
ahead if the gym was for mental health
what was the 10 000 person protest for
that you knew
was just gonna piss off those people
for content right there
there you go man is a good he's a good
man right you're making you're making
points you're a good man
you're a good man michael
just so we're clear i said i'm team i am
wef right now w-e-f-f like win for jeff
team left team white gold yes the
chapman has heard her yes so do they be
apparently
they think you said something bad
and i vote for both but right now
weapon
wait wait we
call and wanna
yes and now you're just talking like a
baby dude yeah it's something weird
[Music]
it's not good
you little michael
michael that's what all these laughs
this is what all those bros who say w
everything sound like will you will
rifle
you want to play winecraft when wham by
willow william
the one thing that i'm gonna be like and
yeah you're like you're right okay yeah
okay got it got it but the gym itself
which is an operating business still
existed in a space where people came
there like in the [ __ ] trolls because
of how important the gym itself is to
them right that was a completely
experience like outside of
the actual gym itself also like the city
kept asking him to shut it down i
remember they had to turn off the power
to the gym you know it's like the dude
really
thought he was special
yeah i mean
everybody had to make sacrifices and i
know you know you know i'm one of the
last ones to defend small business
owners but
from his perspective he's got a business
i'm sure he was losing a ton of money
during all of that and
during that whole period
when the government was asking small
businesses to close for an indeterminate
amount of time i can understand why that
was a panic moment for a lot of
businesses that probably
can't go several months in a row without
with that much lost revenue and
the government was asking people to do
that they maybe should have provided
more support to make that right right
you know
right them the government is the enemy
is the enemy
of the people
so w wan
no you're right
they should have done more for small
businesses
so i do i understand if he's going to
say oh he's just doing this he don't
give a [ __ ] right then he can just
relate it to that and say oh he doesn't
really care but like i definitely come
from a specific standpoint in my life
where without the gym in my life i would
not be here and there's kids and there's
people who i've talked to specifically
in that gym who told me the same exact
thing even during that time thanking me
thank you yeah i mean there's probably a
lot of people that say about a lot of
different hobbies you know that it saved
their life this and that and it's fine
you know i get it it's important to you
remember hassan was very vocal about how
depressed he was because he couldn't go
to the gym because you know he's like a
gym rat thing
he did it though because he was willing
to make that sacrifice right yeah i mean
that's a very real thing for people that
rely on the gym for their mental health
so
get it to an extent
yeah and you know
i eat pizza for my mental health and i
have to stop doing that
so it's not really [ __ ] life isn't
really fair is it bradley yeah i i'm of
the mind that it was a time for
everybody to come together and make
sacrifices so i'm i'm ultimately on your
side of this but i'm just trying since
we're trying you're doing a little mic
there i'm doing a little mic i'm doing a
little mic i'm trying to see it from
here right that's good point of view
yeah i appreciate being at school is
really good for my mental health but
they sent us home dude the kids who
didn't get to go to school got [ __ ] up
sucks
at their prom
they missed all their functions they
missed whole years of their formative
genuinely terrible it pandemics are not
good
we should really try to prevent those
from happening exactly you know they
don't tell you about that
pandemic suck we should really they
don't mention you know try to next time
maybe try a little harder
so it doesn't [ __ ] spread everywhere
just saying
talk about the allegations
talk about the allegations
it is so good
yeah these poor kids didn't get to
graduate that's so [ __ ] up to have
half of your high school experience
taken from you you know
that sucks bro
i just feel like he's looking at the
world in these kind of very narrow
glasses just looking at what's in what's
on his nose and not really seeing the
whole scope of it go home and do some
push-ups bro
these glasses have changed my life yes
do some push-ups some pull-ups go for a
jog
get some equipment even have it at home
just saying
uh the good news account says as an
introvert i love the pandemic so
all right everybody
loves love is a fan of the pandemic
if if you don't
account for the people who died i i
loved it too
yeah if you just you just ignore the
deadly aspect of it
my life's my lifestyle didn't change one
bit i'm not gonna lie it's almost a
little bit awkward to admit but yeah
sorry kim yeah okay i have a survivor's
guilt about it too because like it was
the best thing that happened to me in my
life at the time because i hated going
into the
lottery at the time is that when we
hired you uh yeah i mean that's when i
really got into the show too and started
submitting content
but like i was working remote full time
instead of going into the office every
day and that changed everything well
there you have it i mean where would it
be without cameron us too me and lina
like where would we be without avian
lena and cameron we use our unemployment
checks to buy camera gear
some of some of it and uh
really yeah
i was streaming one day with that gear
and that's when we met
love that there you go
glad i met you baby thank glad i met you
i'm glad my mom has steve
now now i've met someone
how far we've come and the rest
is history
this this is why i'm watching
yeah right there that's right me too
wholesome moments just like that we're
in so deep let's just let's finish this
now for this thank you for this thank
you not just [ __ ] three people like a
hundred two hundred people have said
that to me during that whole time that
like if it wasn't for this i don't know
where the [ __ ] i'd be okay right now i'm
just the middle man here i'm sold on
what you're saying but are there videos
out there of you [ __ ] raging
protests
yes
the good thing about him and the reason
why the show with us happened is because
he's becoming more empathetic to the up
to the opposing viewpoint and and and we
all need to we all [ __ ] need to bro
like like the i'm closed off this person
is a piece of [ __ ] yeah that's true hold
on
even the nike logo on his shoes are
[ __ ] jacked
even his nike swooshes on human growth
hormone look at that [ __ ] you ever seen
a swish that day
what the hell
am i damn
that's pretty funny
let's continue
[Music]
what's happening i can't zoom out now
why is this happening oh god
still exists in a societal place at a
high level in this country
i don't like your viewpoint so you're a
[ __ ] piece of [ __ ] and i hope you die
that is that is still exists do you
think but but ethan but ethan is has
moved out of that and now he wants to
know yo
okay
i don't think we ever wish death
that's merely a little but okay i i see
where you're going with that i don't
think yeah i'm not gonna accept that one
that's why i was like hesitant to
apologize to gideon because like i was
like well i'm not like admitting to be a
liberal racist but okay never a [ __ ]
mad tangent why were you doing that
i think talking about someone
when you're talking like this in an
empathetic way where you're looking at
him and you're like
okay yes i'll think about that that's
very different from what you used to do
what they're claiming that you used to
do yeah you didn't necessarily you know
i've laid it on pretty hard during the
frenemies era that [ __ ] was just like
everybody out for blood
on site
on site yeah yeah and now it's
oops
let's listen to them do you think i'm
sorry i didn't mean to cut you off no
you're good accidentally clicked it
did you want to say something no okay
by the way this is called raw talk
[ __ ]
from raw dog to raw talk let's [ __ ]
i think if i came with like uh gloves on
in my mask i'd be better off having that
conversation he would never bro he would
just walk away he would just he's not
gonna i'm [ __ ] around
he's
gloves on in my mask why were you doing
that [ __ ] yeah do you think if i came
with like uh gloves on in my mask i'd be
better off having that conversation he
would never he's joking about wearing
like a pandemic mask fine yeah
i would probably
just
ask why you were doing that and then
forget about it
that is you would just walk
that's all
yeah i'm sorry sometimes when i'm
watching this and i'm trying to squash
the leaf he says i'm an [ __ ] i'm a
[ __ ] hater as a [ __ ] and even in my
peaceful phase it's just hard not to
you know that's part of your personality
yes
to ridicule people but i like bradley i
mean i i don't have a problem with him
he seems like a nice guy i'm glad he's
jacked those calves will [ __ ] make
you know
put my head in there pretend i'm a
watermelon
uh but
like him he seems nice cool
and i would be happy to talk to him
anytime anytime
bradley if you're watching
so the way they said that i mean i i am
not up to date on the lore but is is he
not associated with nilk anymore yes
yeah i'm not sure he said he was doing
videos with knock so i don't know
the way that he referred to it made it
sound like that was past tense like he's
not really
part of that collective anymore so i
don't know i guess is there an elk a
scholar here
an elk scholar in the uh in the house
zach zach
um
i couldn't tell you
i don't think he was he ever like really
part of the essential group or he always
just collabs with him he was really he
was really homies with uh steve right
yeah they were homies i thought he was
part of them but it appears he's not so
but even if he is that's not like an
obstacle that's
impossible to overcome
anyway shout out bradley you know let's
talk let's talk let's spray the hatchet
let's be home is yeah let's make peace
with him over zoom though
not on discord i mean not in real life
yeah no i don't i think he could take
all of us i want to make sure we're cool
before we yeah i don't think it's like
that and hey maybe you squash it maybe
you know
we could start an arc where he uh he
gets you jacked that could make it be an
interesting storyline on the podcast
yeah
that'd be a redemption arc yeah yeah
yeah yeah
oh we before we go we gotta watch my
mom's tick tock everyone's talking about
it
my mom put a tick tock that
is
oh boy
made me very
um
yeah here's the tick tock
you know i appreciate she's trying to be
funny but
some things you just
don't say
okay
and now this tick tock is going to go
viral probably it already has a lot of
views let's see
let's see how many views it has
40 000 views yeah it's already like her
top banger tweet
okay here we go mom
embarrass me guys it's donna i always
love sharing things with you
it's so much fun and last night i was
watching this show called uh it's on
netflix and it's called emily goes to
paris it's i was watching the fourth or
the fifth
episode and she has this little
emily in paris any fans here right
that's what i was going to say okay it's
called emily in paris yeah emily right
we're off i watched a few those not
gonna lie but it's like hardcore chick
flick like do chick flick for me right
no fans in here
emily paris i put it on to fall asleep
yeah
she's back in paris by the way she got a
new season she's back olivia might be
watching but she's just emily's back in
paris
okay
little trist and when she comes
downstairs she meets some friends and
her female friend says to her la petite
muer which means little death and in
french la petite muer means orgasm which
i thought was really clever of the
french and where which actually means
death is a feminine word you know in in
in english you've got a ball as a ball a
chair as a chair
but in so many other languages
everything is masculine or feminine and
one of the things that i thought was
really interesting too is
la petite muer which is orgasm but yet
the word vagina in french is masculine
so
go figure
anyways i hope you all have a petite
where by the end of the week whether
it's self-inflicted or you share
you guys did i hated that that made me
so uncomfortable
that was so uncalled for
why did she do that
i mean why not that's that's a that's a
pleasant thing to wish upon people
people all the comments are i can't wait
for you or ethan to see this
yeah i mean it's a nice thing but i
don't know man also she goes inflicted
on you like it's a violent crime
conflicted yeah afflicted a
self-inflicted orgasm
i don't know i just i don't like this
whole topic's meshing
you know what i mean it's just uh
which is orgas
the word vagina in french is masculine
you're getting too comfortable on this
app yeah
hey moms am i right
forget about it
so
go figure
anyways i hope you all have a petite
where by the end of the week whether
it's self-inflicted or you share
just don't like it
i don't like it
it's funny though shut up mom i mean
it's a it's a banger it's a banger
all right well apparently we've been
going for four [ __ ] hours yes sir
this has been a marathon it's been fun i
told you guys it was going to be a long
ass app
maybe you were worried we didn't have
enough content
yeah
fell asleep behind me
yeah this was a bang and we still didn't
get to the trailer [ __ ] love
it's like wait what time is it sleep
well he's not asleep but he he looked
like he was dozing off a little bit oh
i wasn't those now but the reason why
mckenna juiced out today is because i
have a very very bad what's it called
[Music]
heartburn oh
oh [ __ ] yeah are you taking any antacids
or anything for that no because it
happens so uh irregularly i think it's
called uh so i don't ever get to like
but so you should get tums or alka sets
or that's that's great for
uh infrequent you know
heartburn situations
yeah i'm saying i'm looking thank you
yeah
anger gang gang yeah i'm girded out
because it only comes when i sleep and
then my [ __ ] throat is [ __ ] up for
like two days super annoying i wanted to
tell you
pokeyman got back to me she wants to do
the pod with us which is great
but i want to tell you love that she
sent me a message
and a picture of you
saying no i was cackling when i saw the
mini portrait of me no
is that real yeah yeah yeah
i'll send i'll show you
you got noticed you got noticed by
senpai let's go
oh thank you guys thank you thank
i'm of course you very big deal to make
something here look in the chat i'm
showing you the receipts oh [ __ ] yo
but she says we'll pick a date into
september to invite her so remind me
fantastic okay
that's awesome dude holy moly right
yeah now you need to frame that and put
it on the
yeah on the other side yeah yeah yeah
time to start this is big for me this is
big for me
time to start pokeman out of context
yeah yeah
yeah and i didn't think that would be
able to be topped you know this week uh
pokemon well
we make dreams happen here happy for you
thank you guys as a fellow
names do come true i got bobi this week
this is just [ __ ] amazing yeah
everyone's everyone's getting what they
want this week well my friends i'm
glad you all joined us for a four hour
marathon we cried we laughed we thought
we prayed
actually we didn't pray we didn't talk
about the tanner thing talk about the
allegations we talked about the
allegations
i can't
all right i gotta go it's super late i
was uh yeah anyway thanks for watching
everybody love you guys so much the
greatest family in the game
guys come on i'm not getting game b i
already apologize to the cats
meow wow
i mean i don't eat
please
okay i'm not getting gang banged by
[ __ ] cats
don't put that on me
[Music]
foreign